what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the
pregame before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in um a couple
announcements before we start the show
the first thing guys all super chats
will be read today over what dollar
amount
King what do you want 10 20 20 over $20
we will read the super Super Chat so if
you have a question comment concern feel
free to Super Chat it I will be reading
those also guys um we are saving we want
to get a kickout cam you know just in
case not to everyone's gonna follow the
rules today but but just in case we do
want to get a kickout cam so all super
chats will be um used for a kickout
camera also guys um make sure you
subscribe to our two clips channels just
pearly Clips um and pearl daily make
sure you go subscribe to both also guys
how many likes to open up the chat today
King okay 1,500 likes and we will be
opening up the chat for now it is
members only so if you want to be a part
of the Chat sign up for the $5 tier um
also guys $10 tier you get our Discord
are behind the scenes Vlogs if you want
to see me freestyle rap sign up for the
second tier I'm good don't let them
don't let them tell you different all
right third tier you get to connect with
me on social media and a fourth tier you
get a one-on-one call with me once a
month so if you want to learn how to get
a million subscribers in a year sign up
for that I also just got um we have a
new Talent Christine and we just got her
monetized in her first two weeks here so
if you want to learn how to do YouTube
bigger better than ever sign up for the
fourth tier also follow my Instagram if
you have any show topics for our new
podcast Pearl daily you can submit them
to me there um that's just pearly things
one there are like three accounts
pretending to be me but it's just pearly
things with a one at the end that's me
um also guys um I think that's it for
now oh we are looking for new YouTube
Talent we're looking at opening an
office in Vegas so if you guys want to
be a part of that if you want to apply
to be YouTube Talent we're looking in
London and Vegas so um DM a clip of you
like talking or something and your show
idea to my Instagram just pearly things
one okay um so guys welcome to the show
so starting why don't we start with name
age relationship status and a fun fact
about yourself starting here go around
and then we'll do second
row okay so I'm Laura 35 um single and
fun fact is I have a boat
license um my name is Lily Phillips the
massive hore um
22 um I am single and ready to [__] and
fun fact I can fist my own
[__] wow
hi guys um I'm Alexis Reed I'm
21 I'm single looking for some big [__]
and a fun fact about me is that I've got
a very tight
coochie wow uh my name is Alysia I'm 19
and fun fact do you have as fun of a
fact as
there I need you to like one up it to um
she's got big tits fun fact I got my
boobs done in turkey and it went wrong
so yeah did it really get what went
wrong well apparently I got a mono boob
so yeah what monck together well I don't
think it is actually but it's a funny
look great to me they look very juicy
I'd love to suck them so thank you wow
we're just finding love on this show I
see there you go go ahead hi there my
name is ARA matcha I am an author and
anti-feminist from London and I have a
YouTube channel called the rational
female where I discuss anti-feminism
from a very modern uh non-traditionalist
perspective just a modern woman's
perspective and I consider myself a
women's Advocate and an equalitarian and
believer in equal rights for men and
women thank you that's a bit of a
mouthful all right Al be 41 single and
fun fact boxing coach 41 that's nice and
you've been on before right I yeah yeah
welcome back welcome back than for
having me back go ahead hi I'm Michelle
I'm 32 also at lady. Harley a83 and fun
fact about me is I am a motorcyclist I'm
a rider a Harley Dav oh cool she likes
riding you like riding don't
you hi I'm Anisha and I'm 31 today it's
my birthday today Happ
birthday you going to get some birthday
C W is that like your opening question
we love but I just mean like I feel like
on your birthday like stat yeah yeah
yeah the thing relationship status I'm
going to say situationship can we say
that means yes someone's getting you're
just trying to decide if his cock's big
enough for you
yet yeah that's why it's a
situationship go ahead hi I'm shristy
Jade I'm 31 and I'm married and a fun
fact about me is that I'm a singer song
writer and a lawyer as well amazing I'm
Isabella I'm 23
I am currently taken dating and I'm a
DJ very nice very nice so welcome to the
show everybody so today's topic has
modern dating gotten harder or
easier so um for for the single people
on the panel um did you have a question
I'm sorry I thought you were G to say so
so for the single people on the panel um
would you say that it's easy in today's
day and age to find a
relationship so I think it's maybe not
easy to find a relationship I think it's
easy to find potentials and to go on
dates and to you know meet people but to
take it to the next step or have
longevity and actually have like a real
relationship I think that can be quite
tricky in this day and age because we're
so transactional and so um everyone's
moving around and you know do you think
most men want
relationships I think it depends um on
the man but um I think some do some do
but I think a lot probably don't I think
in big cities it's really tricky I think
cuz there's so much Choice like I said
yeah it's it's just there's so much
choice that you you always got your eyes
open and who do you see being more
unwilling to commit men or women um from
my experience and from people I
know I do think guys slightly are are
they kind of less likely to because they
um generally don't want to commit
because for you know when I speak to
friends and stuff they they generally
just think that there's more fish in the
sea so so that can be I think te
technically that's that and more girls I
know tend to want relationships and they
they say they want relationships and I
searching for that okay do you think
it's easy to find a relationship in
today's day and age I think it's well
[__] easy I catch a [__] every
weekend so she said relationship yeah
relationship calm down I'm curious like
um because you guys mentioned before the
show you guys do only fans right promote
it Lily Phillips Alexis by they they'll
they'll go so do you what what's it like
dating with only fans great yeah I I
mean like I have a lot of men like in my
DMs wanting to date and stuff like that
I have a lot of like um guys wanted to
be like Cooks hot wife like wanted to
share me and stuff like that which I
love um and do you like do you is that
what you want do you want to settle down
no no no no no no when when would you
like would you want to get married some
30 years 30 years 30 yeah yeah yeah but
like it depends if anyone take me after
they went of [__] you know what I mean
like Fair Point and does that does that
concern you or no you don't really care
I'm not going to lie I think there are a
lot of dirty men out there that like
[__] so yeah I don't think they
mind
okay come on it's a bit serious on a
serious podcast okay all right all right
um what do you think do you think it's
easy to find a relationship in today's
day and age um I think it's easy enough
yeah I mean if someone doesn't want a
relationship it doesn't really matter
but if you want a relationship it's easy
to find one I mean as long as you've got
a big [__] and a tight [__] doesn't
matter do you think it's easier for men
or for women to find a relationship I
think definitely if you've got a small
[__] it's harder to find a relationship
I
mean so it's all about it's all about
the
what what do you think's more okay I
have a question what do you think's more
of a death sentence on The Dating market
for a guy small I don't want to say it
you scared a [__] okay but um or or
broke what do you think's a bigger death
sentence small [__] yeah death small
[__] or what broke so no job not not
looking either he's just he's just yeah
I'd definitely say a small small [__] I
don't think you get to the the the penis
no it's broke it's broke you're not
getting to the penis I think so so you
think you think the the money is more of
a death sentence cuz it's the start it's
what if he's hot yeah if he he has to be
really hot now I I make enough money on
my own like I has anyone here raise your
hand if you've dated a guy without a job
just curious oh me [__] H for three
and a half years all right so it's not a
complete death sentence there's three CH
he was good in bed so I thought you know
what you just had a massive [__] it was
about 8 in it was very thick and I just
thought I can't leave this [__] I can't
I couldn't leave it I love bouncing on
it every ey how long were you with him
three and a half years wow no job but
just good sex three and a half years he
used to call me a gold digger if he
bought me a McDonald's as
well flatty beard I love it wow um go
ahead personally I don't really care
about the size of it I just like the
money to Hest no she's asking is it
harder for women sugar daddies oh is
um definitely men because women are more
fussy even the fat Tings are quite fussy
these
days fat fat girls fat girls you think
do you think fat chicks have too high of
Standards defitely you think they should
settle a bit cuz they're too big yes
definitely they need to look some of
their own size oh
oh that's true I've had so many fat a
musly man like you're not your fat Ting
like why do you want a musly man I could
be a chubby
chaser well I've had so many fat chicks
come on the the show and say they want a
thin guy I'm like why don't you want to
like matsh they do a t i see it all the
time though couples the guys like a one
and the girls like a zero it's a 10 all
the time between them they're a 10 I
wonder how they find their coochies when
all they
roll oh my God that's F I don't know
okay um okay what about you so I think
that a relationship is fundamentally a
difficult thing because everybody is
quite complicated and because of the
complexity of humans I think that just
the idea of having a relationship we
actually underestimate how difficult it
is to find a complimentary partner
because for example if we think of the
fact that we're all different you know I
think it's very easy for us to say like
whether or not I don't even know if it's
necessarily that dating is easier or
harder today or just the fact that
finding a partner who matches you who
wants the same things in life as you who
wants to share the same things in life
as you is a difficult thing I mean I
know there's one lady who who's married
I'm sure she could comment on that but I
think that just the idea of you know two
people meeting and I think that you
definitely need to have a level of
contentment within yourself and being
very positive within yourself and
feeling that sense of you know strong
sense of self in order to find a partner
who can match you what do you mean by
the it's hard to find someone that
matches you do you want someone that's
exactly the same as you so when I say
match I don't mean is in the same I mean
matches in the sense of like you
compliment each other because I believe
that you know fundamentally speaking
when it comes to a relationship a man
and a woman are supposed to complement
each other and I know that especially
discussing this with previous boyfriends
you know the most important thing is
that you both have those things like
shared values shared interest you both
sort of bring out the best in each other
do you think you need shared interest I
don't think you need to have anything in
common why yeah I just I find you got
six girlfriends so you must have I find
I find that usually when couples have
too much in common it's like they almost
compete with each other I find that like
couples that are more different seem to
work better well you definitely do need
to have shared interest because
otherwise what are you going to what
else you going to have you know to share
I don't men don't really like to talk so
they'd probably be happy to not talk
they just like I don't know how it's NE
I don't know how it's possible to have a
stable relationship without talking say
that definitely
especially been married especially
people who've been married for like 40
50 years you know the idea of both of
you having shed interest having things
well ask the husband if he'd like his
wife to talk less well I know regarding
my parents for example the fact that
they both had you know a lot of shared
interest that's really something which
helped to make the relationship last and
that was really something cuz obviously
you know good sex I think I think that's
more of a female thing just my point of
view I really think it's more of a
female thing than a guy stupid no I
don't think they're stupid I just think
you just said men don't like to talk so
no I said they don't like to talk to us
cuz we just talk in circles and like Yap
a bit more where men are a lot more
direct we do we do women are
stupid
I actually I actually do think that
women as a whole aren't the smartest I
mean it can appear that way when you
have YouTubers like to make women look
really idiotic and I think we are
idiotic well when you have you know on
YouTube very populist YouTubers who like
to use their platforms to make no one no
one makes anyone look dumb trust me you
can't it's easy to make people look dumb
either no it's either they're dumb or
they're not dumb you know I've I've
hadent I've had tons of smart gals come
on here and not look dumb if you're dumb
you look dumb but I just think as a
group if we look in the last hundred
years what we've chosen it hasn't been
the smartest like okay no offense guys
but it's like one out of 25 of us under
35 there are more women wait wait wait
wait one out of 25 of us are under 35
are on only fans and University I I
think I think University makes us Dumber
well maybe that's what you think
everyone would agree with you I'm sure a
lot of academics and professors un all
the man wants you to do is shut your
mouth and put his [__] in it and you got
to respect the girls and only fans they
make money like you got to respect the
hustle because they're making an effort
like you know it's business effective oh
no I agree I don't think I actually
don't think that going on only fans is
actually really bad thing I think that
it depends on people's uh life
circumstances well no I was going to say
life circumstances cuz for example
people who are very poor like I wouldn't
really look down on a woman for doing
lonely fans is I'd want to look at the L
fans Lon fans context poor well I don't
know I don't know anything about you no
but you just said like more people on
their background are likely to be poor
if they do any funds well I definitely
think that you know there's definitely
something to be said for say women of
more impoverished backgrounds choosing
to say what do you think SM what do you
think what do you what do you what do
you think's smarter what do you think's
smarter doing only fans or not doing
only fans only only fans okay I know
what you guys are going to say I'm
asking her I mean it really depends on
the contest cuz you could say answer the
question yes or no I'm answering the
question darling um you could say that
choosing to do only fans is actually a
very smart choice if you say a woman
who's very attractive and doesn't feel
like she has any other options you could
actually say that okay can can an
attractive woman marry Rich yeah I think
anyone
can okay okay okay okay so is it better
to depend on one man who loves you or a
bunch of simps that are paying you 5.99
I know what you guys your own money I
I'm asking in general I know every
person's different but if we have to
pick one what's a better choice I mean
again it depends on the one no no no I
need one I I it's not really a yes or no
question because it does depend on the
circum this lady answer attractive woman
marrying a rich man okay thank you thank
you or an attractive woman who her own
money good so I mean she can do that my
own opinion though so I think that
attracts women should marry a rich man
why the [__] do you need to do work if
someone could do a for you to be honest
do you not like being independent you
can be independent but that's why you're
brainwash and then you're single when
you're 45 and then you're wishing you
did it oh M I've got so many guys in my
DMs like I won't be no because if you if
you marry a rich guy that doesn't like
mean that he loves you aren't and also
if you marry a rich guy then like he's
just going to think oh you have to do
this you have to do that like just cuz
he gives you money you can pay for a
chef money he's taking care of me it's
not really handing it to me a man that
has money doesn't mean that he takes
care of you like I know do do you expect
do you expect guys to do anything for
you in a relationship no you don't
expect them to take you on Dat just lick
me out once in a while but that's about
it well no don't you think a
relationship should be about two people
putting an effort together 100% but it's
two it's two different types of efforts
women are way more emotional and I'm not
here to provide for my man to take him
on dates okay and he's going to take me
on the dates it's just how it works I
feel like men and women are different
they're not the same I don't give a [__]
what anyone says and that's the facts
yeah no I agree with you that yeah one
as a [__] one as a [__] and no that's
exactly where it start that's exactly
where it starts but my whole my whole
point is I just think as a group we
don't make the best decisions when and
I'll you know when we all when we yeah
as women cuz we all could have we all
could have like at 22 just like married
rich you know don't you think that's
superficial very why would you not just
want to be rich yourself exactly take if
well then where's the female Elon Musk
we can't figure it out like go you know
what's funny the top B fans models tend
to work for men that's true that manage
them so we can't even figure out how to
sell sex better like most of the time
when women most of the time when women
sort of you know honestly nowadays kind
of you know most women that make a lot
of money monetize Beauty in some way so
we think we're so much smarter we really
just monetizing Beauty that's why
feminism makes no sense it's smart for
women to monetize Beauty if that's the
only thing they've got to work of like
you got the hospit some of us have only
got one thing to work with then it's
there well well but that's the point
it's like we could have married rich but
most girls we don't think that and I'm
like all most most rich guys like you
don't I don't really think like most
rich guys are attractive don't to go I
could never get with a guy just cuz they
have
money you can marry you can marry you
yeah I was like you can marry average
too I was just using rich as example you
could marry average and he could provide
you a middle class lifestyle I don't
want a middle class lifestyle also Rich
that's that's the point is women
nowadays we pick we pick um materialism
over a family Rich guys are more like to
cheat to be
honest most I love men that
cheat I appreciate the honesty cuz most
women do they just won't say it most men
cheat anyway like if you think that your
boyfriend's not cheating on you then
you're deluded but why do you like it
then because like he just spices a
relationship it's a bit toxic like he
goes and [__] another girl and then he
putside I mean there's there's
biological reasons why we feel the way
we feel right so like I've heard pickup
artists like pickup coaches they'll go
out with a ring because more women
approach them when they have a wedding
ring
on she loves married married and and and
so it's basically it's pre-selection
because back in the day we would have to
look at a guy and and decide if he could
take care of other women cuz could take
of the other wom he could take of us so
there's like there's evolutionary
reasons why we feel the way we feel not
only that but it's horny as [__] if you
got meet a guy he's married and then
you're [__] him I
definitely so you you prefer wait you
prefer to hook up with married guys over
n definitely if they've got a girl at
home and they just [__] in the shower of
you no but it's horny
like do you do you like seek out married
men I won't personally but if they come
to me they come to me do you not like
feel guilty about it but [__] someone
else's husband it's you know what it's
their problem it's them it's them the
one who are [__] you like they're the
one who are in a
relationship it it's nothing to do with
me you still willingly walked into that
bed so it is it takes two to tango bab
yeah but like I don't really care if the
guy Che it's not literally for you guys
every a go yeah definitely that's it so
your game is it's got nothing to do with
the guy in it I mean it's got nothing to
do with the girl sorry that's what I
mean
the guy's the one that's doing the wrong
but would you not if the guy the guy was
if you knew he was married would you not
think oh no I don't want to touch you
because you know that's immorally wrong
and breaking up a family it's kind of
horny well you don't you don't think
you're in the wrong too you know what I
don't really care
like you're young you'll learn when
you're older no but it's his problem at
the end of the day like he's the one
seeking out girls yeah but what if the
[__] is crazy cuz if it was me and my
husband was going out and [__] a girl
and he came home to me I'd be like oh
he's still coming home to his wifey I
don't really care he's you wouldn't mind
if your husband was cheating on your P
you're fine with it you're in an open
relationship then that's not
relationship no open on his side not on
my side but have some self respect like
it's not about
respect you on your man to be into you
not not him to [__] everyone else when a
guy [__] someone it doesn't mean
anything doesn't mean he loves no it
doesn't but like some self-respect if
that man's yours that man's yours like
but wom I I don't share my toys for that
particular reason sorry but I find it so
sad that you're this desens desensitized
about relationships and love and sex
it's woring yeah but love and sex is
different for guys though they're two
different things guys that love a girl
doesn't mean sex and love is two
different things definitely different
but guys if you're if you if you married
someone right you made a contract like
you marage doesn't mean anything
nowadays you can marry someone you can
have people get married for no reason
apart from the women waning a wedding
dress is it the drama do you guys just
like the drama I just find it like
married men when they fancy you just try
to be real for that's I mean
ATT just like so you just want attention
yeah yeah it's the attention from it and
stuff like that so what were you not
getting the attention from anywh ads no
plenty ATT men pay for her fans what I
mean they they the ones who are watching
it got it okay can I women's fault for
picking [__] husbands and it I ask you
girl a question what made what made you
ladies decide to want to do only fans um
honestly no I've always been like really
sexual like hypersexual like I don't
think that's a good or bad thing some
women just have higher sex Dr yeah and
and then I was I was doing it for free
anyway you know I was spreading my legs
for free and make some money on the side
but I don't understand like the the in
10 years time when you hold 32 years old
you're going to be with a man and then
your kids you going to have kids one day
and they're going to look back and find
porn of you like I don't do porn I don't
getting vagina or tit do you know what I
mean like are they not going are you not
going to be ashamed in that sense that
you know what in they can cry in a
Ferrari I think you say that now but
when it's like actually in real life
happening it's going to be a total
different situation personally I mean I
don't want kids anyway so like I you
know it's my life I'm going to live my
life I didn't do anything that I'm going
to be ashame can I ask you a question
have you been in love before yes you
have yeah cuz it just sounds to me like
you haven't because I I don't know there
is something that when you're in love if
you go out and someone else like that
hurts it
hurts like to be desensitized and like I
don't care I don't feel anything like if
you in love with someone you're telling
me that if like they went and cheated on
you that wouldn't bother you the only
thing that would hurt is if they got an
STD and then they gave it to me um going
back to you did you did you change your
sort of standing after you uh that
relationship that you were in love in
because apparently he cheated on you so
that did something change in your in
your like yeah I guess I don't really
care anymore like so basically
heartbreak made you just be like [__] it
no I've always been quite like weird
about sex like I I just I I don't think
it's that deep I don't find sex that
deep like there's sex and there's being
in the love there's like completely
different things relation I think that's
fundamentally wrong because when it
comes to females having sex we release
oxytocin when we have sex with guys so
we bond to them and we have a certain
connection with them men don't release
oxytocin that's why it's different when
a guy cheats it I agree with that it's
different when a guy cheats because a
guy doesn't have that bonding hormone so
but if a woman is doing that and you're
saying you're not feeling anything I
feel like maybe that does come from a
place of hurt more than like cuz
biologically that's what happens
regardless of if you think you're a bad
bee or you think you can have sex like a
man like any woman who thinks like that
probably has a lot of hurt underneath I
don't know I've never gotten like
attached to a guy when I've slept with
them just never no no no no like so what
is love to you then like what explain it
I don't know when you really deeply like
the person I guess and that's not to do
with
sex no okay so what is it then what is
it for you just when you really fancy
someone okay but if it's not physical
it's not to do with sex what do you
define as love who [__] knows what
love is [__] H it's just a feeling
isn't it I think Love's an action I
don't think it's being but being
obsessed with someone is just an
infatuation if you really love somebody
you care about them and you you make you
take the actions to show them that you
care that's that's what love is cuz if
we say love is a feeling it can go away
and that's why people say I don't love
you anymore and then they most people do
just stop most people do just stop it's
most it's mostly just women that do that
it's not really men it's just the women
go back what about men who cheat and
abuse on their Partners I mean let's not
just blame everything on women now it's
like mostly women though it's like
mostly
like 70 to 80% of the time they make up
the stats anyway I really I really I
really think that I don't make up stats
lady well you said something
about
basically basically what what's St on
abortion well you said that one or three
women have had an abortion that's not
actually true it was predicted that one
or three women had that's what that's
what Planned Parenthood says I actually
had a check on that stat and actually it
didn't say that it actually said the
rates of abortion have actually
decreased in the USA
okay all right thanks for letting me
know say something about one in five
people in the USA have STDs I actually
had a look at that one one and four more
than that it said more um 20 2.5 million
cases of STDs were report in the no it's
at some point in their lifetime it's at
some point in their life ssy realistic
to well 2.5
million I think at the end of the day I
think wait say that again well 2.5
million STDs would be 0.7% of the US
population because US population is 235
million and that's the people who report
it because you're going on people you're
going on just guesses no one's going to
report they've had an STD I mean but
they've done they've done they've done
surveys on this too like women say it
themselves and I think I think you can
really with the cheating stat you know
it's pretty similar to be honest I think
it's like slightly less but I think I
think you can I think you can I think
you can more likely find out just by
asking people and coming to conclusions
because like you can honestly get a stat
to say anything there was one study by
The Institute for family studies that
found that going let me are you gonna
are you going to let me talk you if
you're going to no it's not your show
chick like so so wait your turn I I
really think that at the end of the day
like we can come to conclusions based on
what we see in real life because you can
find one study that says one thing and
one study that says another that doesn't
make sense are are you are you are you
going to let me finish or no because if
you keep interrupting me you can go kick
out I told I told you I told you you can
challenge me but I've told you to stop
interrupting me and you did this last
show too I have no problem going back
and forth with you but if you're going
to talk over me every single time you
have to go I'm not talking of you every
single time I okay but okay are you
going to are you going to if you're
going to be combative you can go well
it's a discussion I I have no I have no
problem having a discussion with you but
we we've done we did this last show too
okay I think it's important to not
necessarily say things that are just
deliberately designed to make women look
bad on purpose well it's not that I'm
trying to make women look bad but I
think when you look at you know from a
historical point of view like the last
hundred years what do we have that men
value and and I'm just genuinely being
honest like 100 years ago 85% of women
were virgins and we could go back and
forth on the stats and you could say
okay it's not one out of three it's one
out of five that's still bad that's
still not good right and so I think I
think I think I'm I'm not and that's the
point matter if she's a vir she can
still speak like but this is this is my
point is you're you're going to go
personal right and I just I think and I
think like the point is I could say it
would have been a better outcome for me
had I waited I think it would have been
a better outcome for most women had they
waited and I think we have a culture
that doesn't tell women that that's the
most valuable thing you have and I just
think it's lying if we're going to go
back and forth and you're going to say
oh well it's one and five one and six
one and S who gives a [__] it's bad like
a hundred years ago we had um I think
3.4 kids I've seen some stats that said
five we had more children we were more
married we were on less anti-depressants
so it seems like the more power we get
the more freedom we get it just doesn't
go well for us and I think and I think
when men build all the buildings they do
everything in society do all the hard
jobs in society like I think it's it's
fair to say that men are smarter than us
by and large that men make better
decisions than us by and large I'm not
saying there aren't smart women I'm not
saying there aren't good women but if we
look at the standards of 100 years ago
we'd all be thrown out myself included
I'm not saying I'm so much better you're
so smart I think you should be a man and
so just chill out chill out but but so
and this is this is my point this is my
whatever do you think that do you think
that the percentage for um wide vaginas
was more than if there was more kids
like back in the day girl I don't know I
don't I don't know why I don't know why
you make everything sexual this is this
is crazy but that that's the whole point
is I think we have to draw conclusions
about a society and the problem is women
have entered the academic space and so
half of these study like the gender
study you know how they they mess up
these gender studies departments they
make these really biased like studies
and they can tell water isn't wet when I
look in the real world I see women
cheating more than men so I don't need a
study to tell me that I see more women
posting thirst traps on Instagram I see
more women monkey branching I see more
women leaving marriages like I'm not
blind I can see what's in the real world
women have got [__] yeah yeah yeah I
think this is like the only fans workers
are tell it's just Society has changed
and what's acceptable now was not
acceptable like 20 years ago like you
wouldn't see women like selling their
vaginas and [__] getting paid for like
you do whereas back in the day it was
porn it was a taboo so well there's
always been sex workers that's like the
world's old world culture now
everything's more acceptable think we
got we got to look at what what is good
for building families and like you know
and it that's not the end goal to life
you know you don't have to be born to be
a woman to I want to get married I want
to have kids you have to but my point is
like when men do everything what value
do women give back women a minority in
most of the industries you talk about so
you say men have important jobs so do
women but they're just a minority no no
I I don't think I mean yeah but if they
left work tomorrow the society would
still run F the man left a job that
would be exactly
same okay okay okay could a women build
this building yeah why not oh come on
same capabilities
Mand have you SE have you yeah yeah I
have no they could not build women work
in construction why women work in
construction women work in engineering
women work in town PL okay I actually
and here's the thing again again again
again I look in the real world right and
I'll I'll show you a comment that I had
from a guy that works like 50 years in
construction and I get these types of
comments all the time like I talk to the
workers outside and and it's like a very
common theme where so let me let me find
it women left the world then the world
no no I said I said the the world would
not still run no no the society would
still run why in this in this Society
this is the first time we've ever had
women like working in in large
numbers why for for all of history we
hav always walked through they've always
worked they always they've always worked
they have not been the majority that's
not true they have not
been Jes women are still here men are
still here quiet quiet quiet stop stop
so so this is what one of the one of the
see it's like if you tell guys to stop
you see you see him quiet look
at he's the minority in this so sh okay
okay um so he said I work in Building
Supply lumber yard there are five women
I work with I have 40 years of
experience in the field of construction
my job now is to help them do theirs and
we're all equally paid that's just misog
that's because he's a man he doesn't
doesn't take a penis to build a building
doesn't take a penis to do lots of women
do not have the strength of men this is
delusion if you think men don't
physically put bricks on bricks bricks
bricks they I just saw men putting
bricks outside today you are you sing me
you're not capable to do that no I am
not capable of what's do what a shame on
you because I know if you had the woman
this room could do women could do it
they
would we don't want to [__] be
outside they had they had two it's a
choice they they had two people on love
Island and they had men and they had
women they had to rescue the women
within like two three days scrip fabri
of the gender that that particular
individual is IND so I just okay I want
to get this straight I just want to
understand your point of view you really
think that women could do work at an oil
rig yeah cuz they do they're always on
Tik Tok they're not even working I see
them on Tik to that's that's the
minority that you do see the other the
other percentage are doing the job okay
okay you think that we could equally as
well okay you you know so if 99% of
construction workers quit tomorrow we
would just figure it out yes you know
because you know back in the day back in
the 1940s where when when we went to war
women were the ones who were creating
the ammation women to hold yes she's
right she's right abely during the first
second world they were in no wait chill
they were in factories it wasn't they
weren't building the building ping the
roads I mean you could do a factory job
you can't build the buildings [__]
right I could absolutely I challenge if
women could do it I will pay you if you
can I swear to
God do you think only fans is an
important
job from world wars only F she
said J yeah yeah no I don't I think that
I think we should worker through Co I
love you know so I think we should ban
it I think we should get rid of it what
how are all the guys how are all the
guys going to like chill out a bit if
you think about it back in the day men
would pay for porn and the porn industry
the People The Producers the directors
would be the ones making the money
they'd be the pimp basically but you've
now got control of your own money you
control your content what you put out I
respect hustle like there's nothing
wrong with that it's just it's exactly
the same industry that's happening you
just have control of it now as opposed
to you're getting paid by like a pimp or
a director or whatever you'd call it
yeah it's great go subscribe L
Philip also you could become a doctor or
lawyer any of the other things that you
decide we couldn't become a doctor we
get the same wage as them so no more
yeah see and this is what I say we live
life on easy mode she's not smarter than
a doctor or doing a more important job
not is why would I want to go to un for
like [__] years and I can just fing
get my wait wait wait what job what job
do we
do that's more no that's where we're the
majority and we run the field we come
bucket that's our job gynecologists sex
workers gynecologists are we are we the
top of surge I don't know have stats but
I don't know but a woman is a woman is
capable to sex is good job you seem to
be okay with that are you okay with that
P CU you're saying all these stats
saying but are you saying it in a way
that you're okay with that is that fact
is it factual that guys just do better
jobs and we can't do them that's just it
I'm okay with that do you feel okay
about it yeah I'm okay with it I'm not
mad like think about it what jobs do we
need what jobs are absolutely necessary
why do you care them if you're okay with
it like why are you talking about if if
you're okay with it if you don't care
about it why is it m to you what do you
what do you mean I mean like you just
said then oh you're okay with it so why
why does it matter why do we need to
talk about if you're okay with it it's
fine we don't need to have a discuss my
my my point is that women are delusional
if they think we can do the jobs men do
the first and second world I think we
are not we're not going to be able to do
the oil rigs we're not going to be able
to build the building get o if women
could do it we would you know what
choose not to I they choose not to no we
have to just cuz we did some factory
jobs in the early
1900 did not build the buildings did not
work on the
oil women do work bu they're not I think
is it's just important at this juncture
for us to point out that the women of
today are nothing like the women of the
of the 60s or the 70s that built no
they're SM in the fact no they not
educated cult one second one second the
women of today are not one mentally are
strong physically as strong that's not
correct is a fact because fact we have
we have way more mental issues these
days we have kids gr with so many
problems yes because we have a lot of
men that are being raised by single
mothers as well so it's everything is
there is a pattern in what we have a lot
of men that want to be women as well
women are a lot more UC 20th cury we're
back in the the reason why we are where
we are today because the men left those
single women the people of today it's
not just it's not just women I even say
that about men the women and men of
today are nothing like the women and men
of the days of old men today don't even
have as much testosterone as men of the
old of Old so it's funny how you guys
think that the women of would be
anything like the women of of old I
think there are certain women who are
who who have the moral stability and who
who do have the same like Traditional
Values which of women back in the day
yes they do because not all women sell
the what okay what percent of women are
virgin you don't care about static what
what percent of women are do matter
because what percent of the man of
Virgin what percentage of women women
the the female virginity is what
matters
matter exactly the same the female the
female virginity is what matters we know
we know the female okay do you do you
think that male and female virginity is
the same why not equality I don't
believe we're equal I think
it's I I think if you ask I think if you
I think the way that they're talking is
abnormal would you agree
age I think we could find more men that
talk like that than women I agree
because
wait wait so wouldn't that indicate
they're different no it just means they
that's individual no no I'm saying if we
could find more men that speak like they
do Di and we more men guys do talk like
that but it's tracking a load of [__] A
lot of the time when men talk like that
but they doing it because that's their
career that's their
job but my my point is that this is
abnormal for women to speak like this
it's not abnormal to men so why would we
think we're the same we're not the same
and can I just say you're talking about
this day and age how women and men
aren't the same as the old day and age
well can I just say like we don't have
black and white cameras anymore we don't
have chuffing telephones with wires
anymore like Everything's changed women
change men change like that was like
what over aund years ago yeah like get
over it we're in a different era now my
my question is what works and what
outcomes does that have for society like
you wait wait wait so every day we come
out with a new clip of someone going
crazy on the streets and if you like if
you look at old
video I mean you see people shooting up
stores now robbing store I'm not saying
it never happened but I
just I think even no I even think like
the cities are different from like 10
years ago from when I was in high school
and I think like women are more crazy I
think men are more crazy and I'm just
saying look at like the outcomes that
you know women being liberated has
produced it doesn't seem to have proded
seem to have produced good families if
you don't think family is important for
a society fine I think it's important I
think stable families to raise children
in is important why is it always about
making like because how else how else do
you like how else do you have a
civilization some some people can but
like not everyone has to you know what I
mean like just because we're women we
don't have to have kids no we're not
saying that you no one's saying you have
to but I'm saying for society as a whole
to keep going is it good to have a lot
of [__] yeah I think
the society as a whole it's good to have
good sort of family values cuz you end
up having good morals and then Society
stands but I think it's quite harsh uh
to to sort of say it's the single um the
single mothers or the the the breakdown
of the family cuz it's the men that tend
to leave the women no that's not true 70
to 80% of 70 to 80% of divorces are
initiated by women and when they're
University
educated girls one can have girls one of
the one of the top reasons is IR
irreconcilable differences I mean it's
different you see different studies
they'll tell you different stuff but
just anecdotally I've had so many chicks
on the show you know honestly there's
been very few real reasons anyone's told
me for a divorce and even even like the
way you just phrased everything you just
said that there's a fundamental problem
with the way you just said what of
Education you literally just said um men
leave most of the time and then they
corrected you and said no women leave
then next thing you said was well for
what reason don't you curious because
there's a lot of single uh mothers out
there who who weren't married or who are
single or who are left with their
children I'm trying to point out I'm
just curious what I'm trying to point
out is the way you went about the
argument because that that way you went
about the argument just shows you're not
even interested in the fact you just
want to make sure that women are on the
good side of it no no I'm interested but
I think that they I think women are
raising kids on their own and I think
it's quite a challenge for them
women there's a good reason but
whenever which men don't even as many
times as women do but whenever men leave
they have to be the bad guys but when
women leave at a an alarmingly larger
number then there is a good enough
reason for it I think anyone that leaves
I see your point I see your point but
wait any guys don't always have to be
the bad guys it's not about that that's
not what I'm saying anyone that leaves
I'm saying the one that leaves the
family home is the one that is probably
all who
whether it's a guy or a girl or whoever
whatever the point is the person that's
left to raise the kids is left to
ra whose fault is it the lever or the
stayer someone's go to in I know I know
okay we're going to make a new rule this
show know it depends we got to pick one
someone's got to stay
though no no no no today's Pearl show
depend on
the in general in we're going to say in
general right we're not talking about we
know we know there's different
situations but if we go in and have go
through every single hypothetical we be
here all day so thank you whoever leaves
is leaving the problem and so whoever
gets staying is left behind on their own
so it's obviously the lever's well okay
so if women are leaving more aren't we
more at fault for the breakdown of
modern relationship the women how can
the women be leaving when they're left
with the kids if they're in a family
home they're left with the kids so they
haven't left no you're making the
argument as if the women
the women are leaving and then they are
left with the kids a lot of the time the
women take the kids with them or the the
government automatically gives the kids
to the women I don't think women are
good at choosing good partners to be
honest wouldn't which is why we our dad
to choose our partners like in the olden
days if my dad chose my partner I'll be
way better off yeah I need an arranged
marriage I need an arrang marriage as
well be married anyone who ends up with
me poor old bastard that M [__] she it's
like dark guys goe your whole thing with
you were saying like how leaving saying
leaving saying and like how women always
left alone with the kid to be honest I
feel like women are always alone with
the kid because they're not choosing the
right man and they're having they're
having children out of web like Wayne
they're they're having children out of
wedlock so already it's it's set up for
[__] disaster yeah agre you're having
kids out of wedlock most the time it's
not going to work I'll tell you that
stay for the K what happened with my
parents my parents separated on and off
my whole life gave me very inconsistent
lifestyle so that's why women are always
alone with children because they're
doing it the wrong way yeah
also guys guys let her finish 95% I
don't know statistic I'm not that [__]
who knows stats and [__] I really don't
like you said live off the real world
and that's what I see all of my friends
single moms because they're [__] baby
daddies or piece of [__] yeah because
historically women are all the ones
who've been the cargivers of those
children so naturally the woman is going
to be left left with a child out
funny that wouldn't happen if they chose
a traditional
man
think are a piece of [__] I think
sometimes women have babies to try and
trap men and it doesn't too men do that
as well men do that as well cuz men are
just sick circumstantial okay what what
were you saying you were saying
something before she cut you off I said
that it's not always that the woman that
leaves the man it's not always the woman
that looks start again it's the women
who normally looks after the child
because historically that's always
what's been the case because
traditionally the woman has being the
one who stays at home
Cooks but why but why are we punishing
the men for doing what they're supposed
to do like you want you got wait wait
you want a guy that protects and
provides right that's what we
traditionally want but when a guy do
does it he loses his kids no one said
that's what we should you should punish
them cuz like men and women are
different men go and build houses women
look after the kids women build houses
men can look after kids there are stay
home dads who do exactly the same job as
women when the women are out there
earning the bread like minority a
minority but it does happen you need
need
that happen we know like duh but it's
like we don't have to we just said let's
not acknowledge every exception we know
there's every there was are exceptions
and you the first thing you say here's
the exception we know we know I think
what the lady is simply doing is trying
to bring up the fact and I agree that we
should actually be holding men and women
equally accountable because we should be
saying that there are men who should
take responsibility if men let meish let
me finish I was speaking no again it's
okay get out go go bye I told you no I
told you a millionth time I haven't done
anything wrong okay all right bye why
why why why do you want me to all right
I'm asking you to go thank you you don't
like the fact that I'm challenging your
viewpoints no I don't really people
challenge my viewpoints all the time I
don't I don't like that you're being
rude I'm not being
rude
okay like
feminists P do you not like it when
people have all their opinions no her
she asked her to stop multiple times and
she didn't there's a rule we were told
the rules before we came so yeah but she
did try and talk a few times and P
didn't let her talk you just told her
show all right all right because it's
not your show if you want to put on a
show and talk when you want to talk show
not that good I've never heard of it
it's only fans hand you don't
know
live streams every Friday and Saturday
oh my God on
Sunday all right um what are we talking
about uh exceptions and women in the
minority okay um and children babies
kids yeah so all right who here thinks
women make better decisions than men no
okay we kind of we agree sometimes no no
remember remember I think I think women
are a lot more calculated than men tend
to be I think men just either think with
their penis or the very gray area
whereas women kind of subconsciously
plan out what will happen based on that
action okay I think that's completely
wrong I think that women lead with their
emotions and men are more logical so we
all know how emotional we get through
the months with our hormones fluctuating
all women all women have fluctuating
hormones through the
month which means they don't have the
the natural that's an exception again
like you keep bringing up the exception
not
excep and progesterone our period comes
every month like we know our hormones
fluctuate so that's one in five women
have conditions like PC don't one five
is an no I have I have a question I have
a question do you really think that
there are women that are not affected by
their period they don't get a no I don't
disagree with it I'm just saying but
it's not always every month what happens
okay so you
agree women are more emotional I don't
disagree no no so you agree right I
don't know why this is like hard do you
just like to disagree to
[__] yes or no like I don't know why
shit's so complicated
for I'll say yes I mean I've seen I've
seen girls like go crazy on me like when
they get their period I'm like oh man
this this isn't a good look have have
you met a woman I'm just curious that's
a guy no have you met a woman that is
immune to her period n even the most
logical women oh that just doesn't think
really hot he's like maybe there's this
one one I would say one how many women
have you met in your lifetime thousands
and so you have one out of a thousand
King I'm just curious have you ever curi
I'm I'm just curious out of all the
women you've met have you met any that
were immune to their period except me
say me say me I'm just kidding you're
the some people no I'm not I'm not see
but that's like no I'm not some people
are worse than others though like some
people of course but I think that again
depends on the individual what kind of
person they are I'm just trying to live
in reality and I person personally think
and you guys can disagree with me
obviously I think that men are smarter
and they make better decisions in
general and I think we can and I I I'm
going to tell you why I think this
because in the last 100 years we've
gotten all this Freedom we've gotten all
this choice and I just don't think we've
chosen well and you would think it's
like the most important thing for us is
to have kids I would argue I know we
don't all have to but I think you know
that's the one thing that women can do
we yeah correct and yet we shoes as you
were saying so terribly we we we we we
make babies with criminals drug dealers
deers and so it's like if we were these
rational decision makers wouldn't we not
do that 100 isn't like having kids like
overpopulating the country given us
global warming given us overcrowding I
think all that okay I think that's fake
yeah and that is a example of what we're
talking about women are so suceptible to
propaganda like that literally how can
you say are so emotional how can you say
the world how can you say the world is
overpopulated when you could literally
take a drive from here to Newcastle and
you see tons and tons of fields without
building yeah I'm not saying
overpopulated I'm not saying
overpopulated in that way sorry he just
owned you that was hilarious no he
didn't own me I'm just I'm not saying
overpopulated in that way what I'm
trying to say is that overpopulated is
in like oh everyone's using all right
I'm going to give you this is your final
warning thank you thank you all right in
the 1900s they figured out that women
are kind of dummies yeah we're kind of
stupid and and the reason they found
that out was because they invented
propaganda and like marketing techniques
basically and they realized that women
could we could be convinced to do
anything like all we really had to do
was wait till 22 be a virgin marry a guy
and boom you didn't have to work for the
rest of your life we fought to work
think about how stupid that was
do then being with the same man for the
rest of your life
know they were they used to be happy
with that so in the 1900s they developed
these marketing techniques propaganda
and they realized that they can control
a population through women so everything
today is marketed to women all of the
politicians are making laws for women
and what have we seen in the last 100
years women got more power more control
and what do we do we were inherently
selfish and we left our families we took
the kids and really disc I would argue
discriminated against men because only
10% of men get custody of their kids and
I think there's nothing more evil than
giving a guy his kid three days a month
I think that's evil most 100% that's not
true I think that's not yeah that most
men want to be with their kids that's
not true no but do you know what they do
they get that's in the marketing and
it's so funny because I know what
propaganda they pushed on women and you
guys just repeat it it's like global
warming so we don't have kids and that
way we can be married to corporations
for forever and it's like all of these
these issues where if you get if you get
married you're going to be abused and
he's going to be a dead beat that's
that's propaganda they literally talked
about how they were going to put this in
the media and just convince us of this
stuff every show someone brings up abuse
every show someone brings up how your
husband's going to leave you global
warming isn't as common but I I get that
fairly often and so it's funny cuz I can
see right in front of our eyes and there
are times were I repeated some of the
same stuff too I'm not immune every
woman is kind of an idiot you know what
I mean so so it's like we we just
because what happens is we see like a
scary story and when we see a scary
story we will always pick security so
that's what happened with Co all that
wasn't the men that were like dying to
get the shot that was the women we were
scared genda and it's the same it's the
same thing with like you know um the the
abortion right it's like we see a video
of a 12-year-old that can't get an
abortion and we all just like run to the
polls and again all this stuff is so we
don't have kids um who is you were going
to say I was going to say something so
um in the family law system basically
the way that the family law system works
now is completely against men it
discriminates against men and when
you're looking at the law it looks at um
making sure that the best interests of
the child are at the Forefront of of the
of the outcome but for some reason they
have decided that children are better
off with the women as opposed to the men
but they' never actually look at after
they've um produce that outcome and the
child is with the mother they don't look
at the child's life and see is this
child's life actually better so men are
discriminated against in in the legal
system and women know that they can get
away with making false allegations of
abuse and I'm not saying that abuse
doesn't happen it does but the way that
it works is like say for example you
file for divorce 70 to 80% of divorces
are filed by women and it can be up to
90 if you've been to
University then they can say look it can
be something as simple as I felt like I
was walking on eggshell with my ex I
felt manipulated I felt uncomfortable
and all of and instantly triggers in
exactly instantly the courts will side
with the woman and take those
allegations seriously because if they
don't then they could potentially be
leaving the child in a dangerous
situation so what happens is there's so
so much of a backlog for divorce that
the courts believe the woman they keep
the child away from the man because of
these potential
allegations then because there's so many
divorces going like in the backlog with
Co and everything that everyone's filing
for divorce nowadays especially with the
no fault
divorce that then the men are alienated
from their children they don't see their
children so this Narrative of like oh
men don't care men don't really want to
see their children that's not true
there's so many organizations now for
men that are fighting hard for men to be
able to see their children and to be
able to have a really important place in
their lives well and I've interviewed
guys that have spent literally their
life savings try just like die like they
haven't seen their kid in like a year
and a half and you can just see you can
see it like find like it just wrecks
them emotion you said you're a lawyer
I'm sure you deal with this all the time
then but it it's so sad like there are
so many guys I've interviewed where I'm
like I wouldn't be surprised if they
committed suicide I feel like it's like
that ego though they just want the kid
for that ego that's not true they care
about their child that's their flesh and
blood and at the end of the day
um like you were saying P um there's
like they want to win for their ego do
you really think that's funny like this
is Someone's Child who they've brought
up and brought into the world and you're
saying ego traditionally traditionally
the woman is be the one who's a
caregiver therefore the law the legal
system leads towards a woman to do it
and yes I completely agree what you're
saying in the 21st Cur keep that well
and they and they punish men for doing
the right thing that's the right thing
if he's gone more and he he's providing
for the F that's what we want them to do
and if he was home they're just going to
say oh he was a bum he wasn't doing what
he was supposed to do it's like they
can't they can't win and so the way the
law was written it it's it's
discriminatory it is discriminatory and
it also is completely outdated like for
example in Sweden you know Sweden is
very Progressive country and they have
it so that like for example even spousal
maintenance in Sweden it doesn't exist
because they're like okay if you guys
really want to be feminists and you
really want to stand on your own two
feet then support yourself whereas here
the women will take the kids take the
house get spous or maintenance child
support on top of that and yeah
like it's three times a man is three
times more likely to commit suicide or
potentially be homeless something like
that statistic after a separation and
people want to act like oh men are dogs
and men are doing all these things men
are having a hard time especially with
the family law system in this country in
America in Australia in so many
countries and it's it's really sad and
it is discriminatory against men 100%
And you said a 100 well you know a lot
of times they rack up legal fees like I
would say 20 I think $20,000 is like the
average I mean I don't know statistics
but like I know most I know I know most
people who pay child support pay how do
bed off pay right how do you it's based
off the person salary how do you know
what they pay cuz my dad has like a
another kid okay so your dad told you
what he pays well he doesn't pay [__]
cuz they okay okay so your dad doesn't
pay child support and so therefore the
rest of the men just don't pay Childs
like how do you know
this you just seem to be arguing this so
strong I just know from like that paid
$1,000 a month in child that's not that
much though like what you pay for
children
it's you know why you say that because
you're desensitized and you make only
fans money and you don't know what it is
to have a real job and for a man to
support himself Alon as well with a
divorce right you don't know how
expensive kids are um I'm N I know what
and this is more propaganda kids are not
not actually as expensive as you women
try to make it seem you women do you
have kids you you have you have a kid no
I don't do you yes I do how much do you
pay like a month band that's of your
business but my point is you don't know
what you're talking about no but I mean
I don't know the statistics but search
it up like how much kids off no no but
that's but that's what I'm saying it's
all propaganda to make people not want
kids poor people have more kids than
rich people like again this is it's all
the same system of them telling us not
to have children but they want it's the
people that don't have kid kids is
because they if they don't have the
money to support it they want them to
have the best education the best out of
life it's Keeping Up With the
Jones it's to put them in good stead for
the future because you can put anyone
into any school fine I went to a normal
school school the schools make you
dumber I went I went to Great Schools I
would say they I didn't learn much from
them I went to both and I'm just saying
that a lot of people do wealthy people
and people that want to you know make
better choices for their offspring then
try and put them in school and so it it
does that does cost I understand the
reasoning but people okay you know what
the average woman how many kids she had
200 years ago like a football team 2.5
something no no seven 200 years ago
there was seven yeah no no conception
Okay who wants to pop seven kids out
that okay okay so so so how how is it
that we were poorer then but we had more
kids CU inflation because of Lifestyle
today today's society everything's
something very clear because it's very
obvious that a lot of people here are
speaking about this issue of kids don't
actually know anything raising kids the
reality is you don't have to be rich to
give your kids the best at life agreed I
come from a family that was essentially
basically an almost middle class I say
middle class family but my father
sacrificed a lot as long as well as my
mom to put us in the best schools they
weren't rich but we we went to schools
with rich people so you don't have to be
rich to to put your your children and
give your children the best in life you
just have to sacrifice but the problem
is people today are too selfish and
would rather provide for themselves
first before they provide for their kids
and that is an issue I think a lot of
people set up that they want to have
like good homes that like they want the
foundations already so that it is easier
when they I don't think that's true I
think I think that no I think most women
are really selfish nowadays I think most
women wouldn't give up their Botox they
wouldn't give up their they wouldn't
give up their fake nails they wouldn't
give up their pound of makeup they
wouldn't give up new clothes they
wouldn't give up their lifestyle for a
family and I think that's why we're
going to see half of women single and
childless I think it's going to be
higher actually I think most women won't
have kids unless there's some changes in
the laws because I just don't see in the
market a lot of wives that are genuinely
selfless you know what what percent of
women would not go on any trips would
not go shopping would not eat out for
years but Dem men do not do that as well
Dem men no men men only men only make
20% of consumer buying decision
decisions I mean let's just look in real
life so why do you encourage what what
do we see like do we see men buying the
expensive clothes the expensive cars I
just think Society I
thinket you know what's funny it's only
the men you see count count the men at
Tesco count the men just walk walk
working average jobs it's only the guys
you guys see because you're attracted to
them why do you encourage women to marry
rich men then if that's how you think I
don't I don't encourage women to marry
best
I'll I'm going to explain it okay I I
don't think it's a bad thing to marry
Rich my point is today a 22-year-old
virgin would have crazy amount of
options because there there's no virgin
I just going to say good find no that's
my point that's my point there there
they're not there so a chick that's a
22-year-old goodlooking in shaped virgin
she's going to have way more options
than most chicks on the market but
nobody thought of that as a strategy how
would you know how would you identify
yourself as a virgin okay okay they
won't know for sure but most men can
tell tight cooch do you really think
that men would prefer that honestly yes
there's an evolutionary reason they
always have to ensure paternity so I
mean I think the value of virginity is
almost how do I put it like because
there's there what as she was saying
there's no way to Ure it that most guys
just don't even ask and assume she's li
like they don't even believe you they
know any differ I say anyone could just
lie about it correct prefer but the
truth I just believe the truth always
comes out and you can tell had chicks
come on the show and say they're virgins
and it's just so obvious cuz it's like
you pick up trauma which which with each
guy that breaks your heart do you know
why most women don't know that men
prefer virgins because most women are
dating to have sex most women are not
dating to get married so you don't know
what married people that want to get
married actually
want true I'm not sure I agree with that
I think a lot of people are dat a lot of
girls and women I know are dating to get
relationships because they want
something stability Rel but not marriage
that's his
point I think I think I think like a
third or half of kids are born out of
wedlock now think that's a lot to the
ages I think if you're under the age of
30 more likely it's being that kind of
statistic that who aren't dating for
love they're not dating to get have a
family the correct you're you're
admitting what guys are complaining
about which is that women which is that
women like sleep with all these dudes in
their 20s and then and then are are like
praying for a hail man do the same thing
as
men do the same thing they just don't
get the S no they're not 50% of men ages
18 to 21 are virgins that's because they
can't get sex they want to they want to
have sex that is the point because women
are them
better if you go to a club statistically
there's more women than men sh thank you
because we're all [__] the same guys
no that's why have some
standards everybody is only 15% of men
only 15% of men are over 6 foot half of
these chicks half half of chicks you
were said you had a boyfriend that
cheated on you most chicks have had a
boy that's the point we're all screwing
the women have treated just the same
that's the I'm not disagreeing with you
but women date up in across mating
hierarchies they always have men women
who are better than them who women are
so delusional that they think they're
better than men nowadays when
we wait then we have nothing to offer
them nowadays we do not what what do
women have to offer in 2023 we don't
give them kids we don't give them Youth
and we don't give them Purity from a
historical and evolutionary point of
view that's what you were supposed to
bring to the table we still you now just
want to so if you give them that then
okay people like that yeah I completely
agree with but then there's other
self-respect women who do give them that
kind of okay okay what's now the new
virgin is under five bodies that's the
new virgin the new virgin someone who
doesn't do only okay no no no I've
talked to the guys you become a hoe at
like 10 now in modern times at 10 that's
like a hoe at right okay are so so wait
so at 10 at 10 bodies this is just like
from interviewing the guys they've
roughly said once you've slept with 10
men you're a hoe before that five to 10
they'll take it but they're under five
is like a godon they're like what no but
wait but in in history in history um
that would have been unacceptable that
two would have been you've been thrown
out you're a concubine now I'm just
wondering are they also sleep with L
I'll answer they want I'll answer this
wait and I think in in the point isn't
like right now we have nothing to offer
as a group one in 25 of us under 35 is
on only fans you know maybe it's one in
five of us have 24 of those one out 25
so to answer to answer your question
100% of women want 20% of men the dating
apps is the number one way people under
30 are meeting
nowadays question was about I'm going to
I'm going to explain it we only swipe
right 5% of the time on dating apps
that's the number one way that we are
meeting what does that tell you that
most wait that most women are sleeping
with a minority of the guys because
we're all matching with the same guys
and sleeping with them and we can find
this just on dating apps and they'll and
now it's crazy we're getting even more
data because it logs like who you meet
with you know how it like that'll ask
them like the women who who you meet
with who you didn't whatever and so it's
like we we have this data and this has
always been known the king had
concubines The Peasant had a wife this
like history it hasn't changed the only
difference now is that it's like it's
more polygamous now in our 30s where we
or in our 20s where we choose monogamy
in our 30s okay but my question was you
said that you had interviewed guys and
they
prefer uh to sleep with women that have
had less than 10 partners they they'll
sleep with whoever they prefer to marry
women marry they'll sleep with anyone
they don't care so their preference is
to marry somebody who's had sex with
less than 10 people but what about them
have they slept with more than 10 or
less or is this just what that's what
all of the men prefer this by and large
they might not they might say oh we want
to we want a [__] or whatever but it's
usually just because they want to sleep
with the horse because I see who they
date and it's never a girl that's out
there so wait it's just a preference no
it's not preference I can actually
explain it a little bit better so if you
to think about it what do women bring to
a relationship they bring the ability to
Bear kids and further the generation so
with that essentially historically women
needed to be pure because men needed to
ensure paternity so that's what women
bring men on the other hand our sexual
um Endeavors have nothing to do with
relationship because we bring
provisioning and protection right so
they don't have to be no we don't got it
but I don't think women's only go is
okay I have a question I have a question
would you ever break up with a guy for
his body count it was too high raise
your hand if you would yeah depends how
far he was 100% it depends I mean this
is absolutely ridiculous you just said
that women have to be pure but men can
go around and [__] whatever they want
that's that's ridiculous okay okay I
prefer if they're pure for sure yeah of
course of course that's everyone's
preference that's a preference for for
women as well my yes or no is it a
preference would you prefer a guy who
slept with less or they can't turn
around to you and say I'm a dirty dog
I've [__] every you going to get in
trouble you never mind I've told you to
stop talking like three times okay I'm
sorry
okay so who who here cares body count
for a guy who cares is whether yes or no
absolutely okay okay so if it's too high
will you break up with him raise your
hand if you would no I'll just look down
on him a lot no at least they've got
more experience what would you consider
High okay okay wait wa just yes or no if
there was a number that's too high he's
perfect in every other way are you
breaking up with him yes yeah but if you
you wouldn't break you just get in a
relationship with him wait wait okay so
out of one two three four five six seven
eight nine women here I wouldn't I
wouldn't either we have one that cares
okay guys if you found out that your
girl you're dating a chick she's perfect
every way and you found out she had an
insanely high body count would you break
up with her raise your hand if you would
raise your hand if you perfect if she
had an insanely high body count
yeah nobody's perfect why would they
just randomly find out they would have
known no no the only the only the guys
guys the only the only point is that
it's different for men and for women we
I don't make the rules but I can observe
what they are this is why marries don't
last though I care I care but I'm not
talking about you I've said said said
that I care does that not matter or well
you're one out of how many and you just
said you're in a situationship so you're
sharing a guy that's true I'm not
sharing true I'm not
sharing sharing a guy I'm
sh that's the point is I'm not sharing
situation 2023 apparently can't say sing
relationship he wanted to be with just
you then he would be your boyfriend but
not yeah but you
don't most women at some point have that
is the point we don't care about sharing
a guy based on what we do we can live in
la la land and say things that sound
nice or I can look at what we do that's
what we pick PA you in a relationship
she said yes oh no she she she's indiff
sorry I don't I don't talk about she
sharing a guy I don't know how
situationship Define sharing either
people could be in open Rel ship and
share situationship doesn't necessarily
mean that you're Shar could you could be
married and Shar the whole point the
whole point is women will share women
have always shared throughout the test
of time the top 15% of men have always
had a bunch of chicks and it has not
been the same vice versa because we've
always had to ensure paternity I don't
make up these rules I just tell you what
they are I've interviewed hundreds of
people women don't care women don't care
men care go ahead how does less bodies
ensure like a woman's going to be more
fertile though I don't get that it
doesn't means you're not a ho and they
don't if you if you drink alcohol every
day are you more likely to do it
again probably yeah so if you have been
sleeping with a bunch of what's that to
do
sleep Jesus Christ um if if you have
been sleeping with a bunch of different
dudes for all of your 20s for a decade
don't you think it's going to be a
little harder to
stop no
really it's a generation you get into a
relationship you're a girl you're not
going to cheat I think anyone under the
age of 20 have got an expectation where
you can sleep with as many guys as you
want and you're not going to get judged
because you're not old enough or
experienced enough to know that you will
get Lo down upon I don't think that at
all because you will have to not care
about what people think you don't but
there's going to be a man who wants to
date you who thinks oh I'm going go [__]
her cuz she slept with well I don't
agree with that man who cares what what
I agree with you I don't disagree with
them saying you are going to get judged
based on the no matter what we do we get
judged anyway when you have no body
count when I have no body count say
too but if you SLE I like you when women
say well I don't want to be with the guy
that is going to judge me but the
reality is the guy that's not going to
judge you you don't want to be with him
either I don't care yeah I'm judging him
as well and I don't I I do care about
everybody judges everybody so my point
is the guys that you would look at and
be like oh this is the kind of guy I
would want to be with more than likely
he going to have the same mentality that
we are speaking about that's why women
cheat them because because of the exact
reason so if you saying the statistics
that women cheat more than men then
that's the problem women cheat mostly
most of the time because they are with a
man that they don't want to be with no
it's because they were that's a fact
it's probably because of this reason man
that she's scared to lose she would not
cheat it's cuz men don't give them
enough love and attention cuz they don't
bother having a connection with them or
maybe it's because
women maybe or maybe it's because women
are never happy I'm maybe it's because
the guy's got a small [__] or it could
be because that's the whole point that's
the that's the you're proving my point
cuz that's like the number one thing
you've talked about and nothing nothing
that makes a guy a good husband or a
good wife a big [__] does to be honest
no it doesn't it doesn't no it doesn't
but again it's just because you're age
you don't you're not old enough to
realize that it's more than just having
aasy I I don't think it has to do with
age I really don't I think it's how your
upbringing is because honestly like I
think you're cool and all but like
you're treating this whole thing as a
[__] joke [__] co co co co like I'm
just
fans subscribe Li I'm not talking about
no but you you're saying this but like I
like you told me you did only fans
before downstairs that doesn't change
that you did it you still did it I've
learned from my lesson and but you still
did it like you still did it's not going
to change that you did it like of course
not but the thing is we grow and we
change and we learn but it doesn't
change that you did well but but her
whole point like you you guys are just
living in delusion okay did did doing
only fans hurt your dating prospects
it it definitely messed up my mind from
19 to 23 for sure yeah I was say this
like I don't care because I'm a changed
person now how old are you I'm 23 and
when did you do only fans when I was 19
just 19 and like how we were talking
this girl was saying it depends on your
situation and it does I did it I got
kicked out I had nowhere to stay and I
said how the [__] am I going to make
money in a pandemic right now I don't
have a degree none of that so I became a
sex worker and was it the right decision
no I don't think so I definitely could
have found another way out for sure but
I wanted the easiest quickest option and
that was doing only F instant
gratification yeah exactly and now I
look back at it and it's like wow that
was so dumb of me and that was like a
really stupid mistake I made but that's
not who I am anymore and I've grown from
that and you know I have a boyfriend now
and that's something I was honest about
with him because that's who I am today
but that's the thing it was embarrassing
for sure nowadays you have to admit that
like thing is cuz you probably did that
during Co times or just before Kobe
times I think it's a lot the situation I
think a lot of people women during that
situation who did kind of go down the
rabbit hole who have exposed themselves
and done lots of things online which it
would to get the inant money because
they weren't able to get to a job so you
now have to live with that kind of shame
but not shamed of it though all no
you're not shamed of but you're not
proud of it at the same
bread of course I'm not proud of what I
did but that doesn't bother me anymore
yeah no I accept that no I said did you
like a change person though that's nice
thank you well and I think too guys
appreciate
reality and like you're not like it's
better be honest you know like doesn't
make you any less of a woman or a less
of no that's exactly what I'm trying to
say is like and same as these girls who
young will that's what when you asked me
earlier like oh do you hate only fan
girls no I don't I don't hate anyone
like I said we have free will as human
beings you could do whatever the [__]
you want I do not care but do I respect
it no we're allowed to have you know
different viewpoints in life that
doesn't mean I'm not going to not be
your friend because you choose to pop
your [__] on the interet do you look
down at them no because it's your life I
don't agree with it that's not something
I would do for myself do I think it's
the right thing no I don't but that
doesn't mean I hate you doesn't mean I
don't want to be your friend am I going
to try to correct you for your wrongs of
course that's what we're supposed to do
if you have an honest open platonic
friendship with someone you should and I
would hope they would do the same for me
if I was doing something wrong that's
what I personally think my friends are
like woo go girl get because because
will lead you down destruction and they
won't be honest with those the girls
you're choosing for your life even guys
say guys say if I was a girl and I was F
I would do it too men wouldn't date you
because you do only fans which is a sad
reality because it's true because again
you are not you as an individual just
people who do only fans are kind of
viewed as less than the normal person
who would have an education get a job I
actually think that most money does mean
it's any I actually disagree with that
cuz most my most the girls I know that
do only fans have boyfriends wait wait I
have a question I have a question
question do they have husbands yes at no
not okay okay so you know one but most
don't I know like a a
lot wait wait so why so why was so why
was your first reaction one oh I know
one because most she okay what do okay I
have a question do the majority have
husbands how do we know
that boyfriend do the majority guys will
date a girl for a couple years and
bounce she's people do it from like when
they're like you know they've been like
from together since a young age and then
they'll both start it it's not like you
know they'll do it together that's cuz
they've got a king I mean that's they'
got a I just need you to answer yes or
no does the majority marri does the yes
does the majority does the majority have
husbands no okay you don't why that's
not relevant if she has a husband or not
she's making a point about but why does
marriage always prob making more money
than on the couch does marriage is
marriage matters because it's it's a
stable relationship with two people that
respect no because like it doesn't
matter if you're married it doesn't make
you so you're saying her marriage
doesn't matter did I say that you just
did your husband's I said that if you're
married I say oh
you're do you think do you don't think
marriage matters not now no like people
get divorced like she's 20 22 she
doesn't know any difference she's 22
sorry I apologies I'm 21 actually 21
sorry I overage you she's 21 she doesn't
know any different she's too young I
don't it's because I've seen like so
many people get divorced like marriages
don't work now like I I I honestly I see
I see your I see your point of view a
little bit right I I understand that
marriage isn't marriage anymore because
most people get divorced but we we have
to admit that getting a guy to marry you
is a far higher level of commitment than
a guy dating you it's a flex H yeah and
we can we can agree that a guy is more
committed when he's married right yes so
the fact that the majority agree with
ially should be okay you don't think him
putting you in a position where you can
take half his [__] is more committed
yeah but you can't you can't I'm not
saying it's good I don't really see it
like that it's just from my experience
I'm not married I've had and a lot of my
friends are but they go through the
motions where they date go out with
something it's steady and it's just like
the next step to get engaged to get
married it doesn't necessarily mean that
they love you more or committed
unfortunately sometimes they just sort
of go through those step she's trying to
be different so bad it's like pissing me
off like oh it doesn't mean they really
love you like it doesn't I'm not saying
that they don't I'm just saying from my
experience from my friendship group that
it's that that's what's happening what
do you what do you think what do you
wait what do you think marriage is you
don't think it's boring going through
the
motions well I'm not married I I I've
Just Seen unfortunately with some
friends it's worked out for them and
some it hasn't they go through the
motions they're in a social group where
you know you get together your friends
and then you know you're dating for a
while
going through those steps and you get
married and yeah okay it's a sign of
them being more committed but I don't
know necessarily they're in love okay
okay do you think love is a choice or a
feeling
[Music]
both um that's tricky
uh a a choice a choice okay so wouldn't
wouldn't they be choosing to love each
other if they're married
um I I it's I don't know yeah they
should be you would age but
unfortunately some in my friendship
groups it hasn't worked out that way and
and you would agree that they're more
committed Under Pressure wouldn't
wouldn't you agree wouldn't you agree
that they're more committed than the
people that are not
married yes no maybe on paper on paper
okay would you agree the men are more
committed no because they're they spent
all this money on a wedding they spent
all the money on a the women on the
surface it looks like they're committed
behind the doors in general they're
cheating and doing all kinds of
right I agree most married I've I've
most married men that I've not
personally come in contact just through
friends and that aren't faithful which
is kind of terrifying for somebody as me
who wants to get married and live that
kind of normal traditional 2.5 are most
women today faithful
no it's complex no again it's it's
subjective like men and women who who
are equal both will do equally as [__]
stuff as the other person would do I
just don't understand why being
unfaithful is like this you know people
used to cheat and they'd work through it
and it didn't have to be the end of the
world so I just don't understand why
we're in this Society where we tell
women that you're the absolute victim if
you get cheated on CU women doad when
most women like they post ass pictures
on Instagram they have open Instagrams
they're talking they have male friends
they're talking to other guys all the
time it's like you know something yeah
go ahead what about like the women who
don't do that stuff like genuine like
Conservative Christian women who don't
act like that and their husband like
they're fully committed to someone
traditionally and they're in like a
Conservative Christian marriage which is
like I want in my life right I don't act
like that on the internet anymore and
they cheat on me then I I don't have the
right to get upset especially under God
and St well I okay I I think you have a
right to get upset I didn't say anyone
can't get upset but
my no I'm not saying who cares I'm
saying I don't think it's the end of the
world and I think it can be worked
through and I personally know women that
maybe their their husband cheated 20
years ago they worked through it they're
happier than ever and I think all we
ever hear in media is like it's the end
of the world and we never talk about the
part the woman played because a lot of
women like demasculate men so much and
they just criticize him so much that he
just wants to go somewhere and feel like
a man I I'm talking like TR
and I and I think it's very rare to find
a wife who's perfect nobody's perfect
correct and so that's my point it's like
let's make sure we're clean and perfect
before we break up going to be perfect
correct and that's my point like we have
to remember doesn't give someone the
right it doesn't give him the right but
I'm saying men are human so and I and I
but they're not exactly the anim they're
not animals right they're not saying
they're
animals I think it's silly to tell women
to leave every time you get cheated on
sometimes I think again it's a
generational thing I agree with you
women now again are more inclined to go
okay I'm done with it because this man's
cheating me he's made me feel less than
I am because there's a thousand men who
are trying to swipe into them slide in
their DMS because they have those
options whereas back in the day it was
like oh no no it's my husband I'm going
to work on it I think it's really sad
that in society nowadays that women
think that's always something better
whereas you can just work on
establishing that way and I interview
like I've heard stories of like moms
where the mom left because she got
cheated on the dad gets remarried the
mom's single is she better off now is
that a better life for her and I like
I'm not excusing it I'm not saying it's
okay but like we were supposed to become
we were supposed to be virgins on our
wedding days but if you think of the
emotional distress of the woman that's
going to have to stay with a man who's
cheated on her you have to constantly
day by day go think who's he texting but
you choose to do
that to over it it is a choice but
marriages you're supposed to do do hard
things and women back in the day didn't
have the choice that's the thing whereas
2023 women do have the choice they have
an option to do better than they have
done to accept well to to to realize
they they expect and they deserve more
than they but see I I deserve see it's
like deserve because women do deserve as
men deserve men deserves I don't think
anyone deserves anything everyone
deserves I think if you Comm if you
commit if you commit into a relationship
and you are married one second if you
commit to a relationship and you're
married it's a contractual agreement
that you have decided you and me we're a
team that's it and if someone breaks
that I do think it's it's too easy
nowadays to do you do you think women we
should break it when do you think men
should break the marriage contract
because we're not coming in as virgins
should they not marry us no they choose
to marry you knowing full fact that that
might not be the case right so they
already know that so that's that's done
and dusted let's get over it now it's
the guy right let's get over it should
men break the marriage contract if a
woman gets fat in a
marriage maybe yes oh wow I mean it
depends why she gets fat right why does
it depend you I
know does does it depend why he cheated
you never you never ask the guys I
wanted to point this out so you said it
depends on why she's getting fat so if
it's a medical thing that's that's my
point but essentially what you're trying
to say is because some of the reason why
women get fat is actually because of
their hormones sometimes I know that
right good so what you're essentially
saying is in a marriage a man has to
deal with a woman's hormone so for
instance when she's on her period we
have to deal with all the [__] that
comes with that when she gets fat
because of our hormones we have to deal
with that but then you never think about
the the problems that men face with our
own hormones which is testosterone
that's true yeah I actually hadn't
finished what I was saying so with
thanks um so with the so if he does
cheat or whatever if he is sorry for
cheating and he really is making an
effort to make it right then I think you
should probably try and make that work
because you've already made this it's
through thick and thin good and bad all
that stuff stuff but if he is said okay
I cheated on you and now I want the the
the the woman I had an affair with to be
my next girlfriend and I don't care
about you then what do the wife is
screwed well it's I think like and again
you know studies can say anything but
the studies I've seen it's like 50 to
70% of the time it's a one to two time
thing yeah so it's like knowing that the
majority of of cheating is a onetime
thing I just think it's in our best
interest to try to get through it and
especially I think it's tough for guys
nowadays cuz women walk around half
naked you know like men have so much
test they should be able to so should
everyone should be able to not naked
everyone keep your pants on I went to I
just went to Vegas and chicks had
stickies on their boobs and they're
walking around no top or a thong and
just you know that's how you naturally
are why not well I I think that's hard
for men like men have all of this
testosterone you know very they actually
don't care about testosterone so you say
women should be able to walk around
naked and in the same bre you're saying
men should be faithful to their wives
but in the same bre you're also saying
that that same man that should be
faithful to you should be able to go out
and accept the fact that every woman out
there should just be able to walk around
naked if you go to if you go to a nudest
beach no one wants to have sex with any
of them and they run around naked all
day long wait wait wait I just need to
repeat this you think that the men don't
want to have sex at nud speeches I mean
maybe one or two but they're all pretty
like I don't like okay wait wait wait
wait wait wait I want you to just
logically think through this you think
that if the naked women went up to the
men on the beach and offered them sex
they would say no have you seen them
some of them wear like sandal and socks
like I don't I need I need a yes do have
self
control I think they're not in the mind
no no I need a I need a yes or or no
they don't go with their I'm going to
ask the question again I'm going to ask
the question again do you think do you
think the majority of men if a naked
woman is in front of them and offering
offering them okay what is she on the
nudest beach what is she naked on the
nudest beach where everyone's naked I
think no one cares okay
we're how much of the population go to
nud this beach you're actually talking
about the niche type of people that go
there
for I mean it's quite a Noel thing right
like so like when I was in Barcelona and
I have a question people top this I was
like this is amazing I have I have a
question as a as a guy for the guys in
the room would it be distracting if
women walked around naked not really I
think they've
allun it would be distracting for like a
minute and then I'll get used to it yeah
yeah he's like trying I always find if I
walk around and enough around like a guy
they don't even like it doesn't phase
them anymore you know what I mean they
get so used to but that's the point like
men are thrown sex at them all of the
time like it's in our media we dress
half naked and it's like my whole point
is maybe we can have a little EMP
empathy for the men but it's like it
seems impossible here like there's like
no empathy at all where we can kind of
understand where they're coming from I
yeah because that's the thing like as
King was trying to say as well like men
produce 70 to 80 million sperm a day so
their hormones are raging and the reason
that they do that is so that we can have
a population on this Earth and keep the
world going so when we know that men
have that biological reality the same
way that we have a biological reality to
have estrogen and testosterone and to be
Moody and not moody and all of the
different things why can't we accept
that that's a biological fact for them
and therefore like Paul said you know
obviously the disrespect and all these
types of things that's not okay we're
not saying it's okay but if we can just
accept the reality that men are sexual
creatures for a reason and that's why
we're all here so if a man is going to
cheat why does it have to be the
absolute end of the world I just don't
think it is because if we know the
reality for men then that's it's likely
that it's going to happen and I think
the crazy thing is the crazy thing in is
in all of biology like if if you look at
different kinds of animals the females
have what you call like a mating
strategy where they signal to the males
whenever they want to mate now when it
comes to human beings human beings are
the only um species where the women use
their mating
signals just to play
around so literally they they they they
dress they dress half naked and then
they put red lipstick and they say we're
doing it for ourselves that is I don't
mind if guys are looking at me like I
quite like it can I just say you can't a
man can't have a kid without a woman so
if you're saying oh a guy needs to come
and he needs to have sex like to produce
kids that's just [__] like how's it
[__] it's a biological reality a man
needs to have sex and and ejaculate to
create children what do you need but he
also needs a woman and an egg as well so
exactly but women don't go around saying
oh feriz my but you didn't listen to
what I said because men produce 70 to
mil 70 to 80 milli just it's as simple
as that yo just because you use sex for
fun doesn't mean that that's what sex
was created for sex was actually created
to further the human race just because
you don't understand biology don't
listen to that's why only fans exist why
these things happen doesn't mean that
what you're saying makes any sense yeah
but that wanking like doing that on on
only fans or men watching corn and all
of these types of things this is not
good for men it actually damages men's
Brains it it damages their dopamine
receptors it damages their relationship
it makes their lives harder so actually
we're using men's biology against them
to make them weaker because when men are
driven by this they they they have less
testosterone they're weaker they don't
it messes up their brains and it messes
up relationships and family so it's
actually not good for anybody at the end
of the day so we should I think we
should follow we choose men that don't
wank I think I think we that doesn't
make sense how can you say we we need to
choose men that don't wank then that
doesn't make any sense why don't why why
don't men just why don't men just choose
women that aren't whors wouldn't there
be a better
solution the point the point is we're
saying that the men cheats so it's like
the man can control his emotions right
and his feelings and his millions of
sperm um so he doesn't have to cheat um
he chooses to and that's where it gets
tricky and okay should should a man
divorce a woman if she flirts with
another guy no but I also said
previously I also said that they should
try and work on it if he does cheat and
if he really is genuinely sorry but also
if you really love someone and you're in
that relationship you you should be
content and full in that relationship
that you don't need but then but I'm
saying the real the real issue is the
women though the women because we can't
tell the difference right now between
wives and single chicks they look
exactly the same they look exact like I
I get from The weding Ring The weding
Ring how is Shing your dick inside
someone the same as a girl flirt and
that makes no because they're both are
mating strategies because it's like no
because because because the way how
would you produce you had to get the
attention of a high status guy that's
how
you to men How would how would men
reproduce there are women in this world
who will pay men to come inside them
just so they can have a child relevant
of a relationship status what's your
point that's no point I'm just saying
why there's no point we just said how
would women how would men I'm saying in
history oh typically how women would
seek attention men seek sex right right
that's just just I just don't understand
what you're trying to say to be honest
I'm I'm saying like if if you wanted to
reproduce historically you had to get
the attention of a guy to get married
right not really range
mares but he would still have to what
look at you right and my point is we
have wives that are actively seeking
attention from other men in marriages
yet complaining that they get cheated
on and and I'm saying it's I'm saying
M's not giv them enough attention and
enough well I mean we're all addicted to
attention cuz we all live love attention
you don't give your woman attention
she's not going to stay with you she's
going to look some well I just think
there's no there's no pleasing
modern-day chicks because we we've had
social media since we're 10 15 so we've
gotten attention from social media like
women I was thinking about this I was
like I think the equivalent of a woman
addicted to social media as a man
addicted to
porn do you get like a lot of [__] P why
do you have to keep asking question it's
really inappropriate it's got nothing to
do with what we're talking about oh
you're
boring
iopr I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna take
a second to read super chats um okay so
Adam Sutton we got a man cheating is
when he buys the girlfriend a house this
conversation is ridiculous uh Purple
Hills currently talking to an O girl
we're talking about seriously dating but
unfortunately I'll never bring around my
friends and family ladies if you meet a
guy you really like an O just know it'll
never turn into anything more than a
hookup uh DB NX 1701 um JC Pearl like
the women on this panel are 5 years old
I know it's hard can you find some women
that actually have more than two brain
cells to rub together and Savage can you
tell the girl with the glasses to turn
off her forehead it's really bright
Christopher SWAT and you're arguing with
Western women majority are a lost cause
please bring on two panel Swedish girls
and British Amic
interrupt the super chats please thank
you love to see them on opposing views
realist versus dumb [__] Flat Earth
or denier show these women a video of an
eight-year-old boy beating up a fully
grown woman or one of the woman's Soccer
Team losing to high school boys 60 46
and two um someone explained why Kanye
has to pay 200k a month for child
supporting Kim Kardashian is a
billionaire uh enter black dragon the
modern women live in fairy tale land and
use language of mandry to try and make
points rooted in the in the lies of
feminism what I'm hearing is they do not
understand who or what men are or how we
operate biologically or socially uh
Robert Benning thank you for the super
chat um sain finest um Pearl doesn't
make you ladies look less smart you do
that on your own case in point the two
in the middle you guys you ladies still
support them what do you think that
reputation gives you ladies a page
ladies uh I'll ask that question later
Matt butcher Matt butcher Pearl you are
becoming tops in handling chaos best
best couch of Shame yet how can they I
need you guys to like can you guys stop
interrupting the super chats please a
thingl a rule before we read the rules
before we started it's not even us
trying to be mean like just follow the
rules uh Pearl you are becoming tops and
handling chaos best couch of Shame yet
how can they argue with the general
behavior of women and just look what's
happening in in the room it's hard to
believe I'm looking I'm looking right at
it um Matthew corn way the delusion and
indoctrination runs deep poor Society um
Joey cornay the two in the middle appeal
are so so shallow they make Kitty pools
look like Marana trench they're cute but
vulgar and give off Vibes of being more
ran through than the tape at the track
meet Sancho Sano B um I don't know why
they all want to do it like three to
four times a day good luck if you have a
much higher Drive in libido Joey I feel
like if I hooked up raw with the girls
in the middle I'd contract T
tetanus it's not disease I know the
ginger Menace hi Pearl I'm glad that us
women have a positive role model for
women thanks for letting me moderate for
you this evening I hope blesson got my
email I know how busy he is I think I
made you a moderator um soncho B 2inch
gang is okay just make more money James
King social media has set a standard for
perception exceptions and paints a
confusing picture for most um hey Pearl
why do you want to be picked so badly
and why do you look like a fish from my
local Whole Foods
location you know what's funny I got
this dress at Whole
Foods I now King was roasting me earlier
okay um let me see um enter black dragon
men's biology testosterone is tied to
our sexual appetite to reproduce
feminism has tried to condition men to
control his biological imperative while
telling women to be out of control and L
Adam Sutton a man cheating oh I read
this one okay I'm going to find the
question cuz someone paid to ask a
question let me find it I think it was
page um also guys make sure you like the
video how many likes are we at King will
I find this a th likes a thousand guys
so when we get to 1,500 likes we will
open up the chat oh I think it was oh
here it is okay would you guys want they
they want to know if you would want your
daughters to do only f
of course they would yeah yeah of course
I wouldn't mind okay would but I don't
want kids so like I don't really okay do
you want
kids pardon yeah I do yeah um I it's not
that I wouldn't want my daughter to do
anything she wouldn't have to do it
because you know I'm going to provide
for my children so my mom encouraged me
to do
it both my parents like my parents are
all still together they've been married
20 years like they're very okay and how
did how did you get the idea to do only
fans I was literally just being as [__]
as it is so I thought you know may as
well get paid for it but it was it was
just because I actually enjoy I I enjoy
sex very much and so I thought you know
what I can profit and so you told who
did you tell first your mom or your dad
um I think I told no I told both of them
at the same time and and what did they
say they said as long as you're safe and
you're happy that's all that matters
okay but they didn't say go do it they
just said as long as you're safe no well
like um when I was doing I was already
doing like Instagram promotion thing and
my mom like was like why don't you do
that you know what I mean like why don't
you do any fans you may as well okay so
your mom encouraged it yeah yeah she
said if she was my age and like in this
generation should do it yeah that's what
my really your your parents said the
same thing yeah how how did that
conversation go um it was just H it was
just cuz I was already with um someone
who had like a social media and stuff
and then we were seeing on social media
together and then we just had the
conversation about only fans and then
was like yeah do it like if you're
comfortable and like if I was young and
I was your age I'd do it too okay do you
expect to get married
later yeah I don't really care to be
honest I'd like to get married okay I
mean um um if I get married it doesn't
necessarily mean that I'm going to stay
in that relationship that I'm going to
be happy for the rest of my life like I
do think if you're married I think you
should stay in the marriage yeah I do
and if you have children you should but
I don't really think marriage is like a
NE like I don't really think it's that
NE necessary I mean it's not the same as
it used to be obviously um and I mean
getting married now like I mean you
still get cheated on you
still you still get
cocked have you ever seen a successful
marriage yeah well my parents have yeah
so then why do you have this view on
marriage because um I have this view on
marriage because a lot of people that I
know get like I've seen a lot of people
get divorced I've I've personally met
met like guys like I literally met a guy
actually once in a pub and he was trying
to like um chat to me and stuff and he
was like trying to like ask me to go out
of him and he on his lock screen he had
a picture of him at his wedding getting
married to his wife with his children in
the picture as well and I just think
that like marriage doesn't like stand
for anything like it doesn't mean
anything really I I don't think it
really means a lot and and you also said
earlier that um if you're married you
get half of what your uh partner has has
but that's not true either because you
can actually a guy can actually sign all
his money to himself and not give his
wife any of that so that's not true
that's yes true I know someone that's
done it yes it is true was it a prenup
or you saying that this was a court
ruling prup no it's not a Court ruling
I'm saying that they can do that before
they get married so it doesn't really so
it was a prenup yeah so that why does
that that's not relevant doesn't matter
yes it is relevant because if it's a
prenup or it's determined by the you can
still get married and not you really
okay I have I have a question I just I'm
just curious how you think so you know
usually if I'm in a room with someone
that knows more than me I'm not like
okay so she's a lawyer you're on only
fans and you you think wait wait wait
wait wait it's not about money oh my God
it's not about money and so you're
talking about the legal system and I
know a good amount because of the
documentary I'm doing on the legal
system but if she told me something I
would probably believe her just that she
wait wait wait
I never said it was so but but I'm
saying you're arguing with a lawyer I'm
not arguing with her I never said that
it was disagreed with what I said when I
I'm just I
just I just I just want to understand
how you think lawyer only fans worker
you think you you know more than her did
I say that you acted like it no I didn't
I don't even know what she's talking
about I just said
I make more money than her saying I'm
saying that I know someone that's
married and that
give all give you heard okay let me let
me let me just let me just repeat this
let me just repeat this heard let me let
me just repeat this let me just repeat
I'm going to repeat this really quick
really quick for us heard a story works
in the legal system as a lawyer I
haven't heard a story I know someone who
couldn't give their wife okay who told
you what I'm not saying someone told me
I know someone personally that okay that
so you know someone that told you a
story no I never I never said that I
know someone personally like were you at
the court hearing none of his money goes
to wife were you at the court hearing
why does it matter like what are you
talking about my point is I don't
understand why you have this gut
reaction to argue because you're saying
that I said that I'm right and she's
wrong I I said that you argued with her
and I don't think you understand how
you're coming across okay I don't really
care I'm just that's clear that's clear
all right okay so I'm I'm saying I don't
understand why you're acting like you
know more than a lawyer so why don't you
so I would love to Okay so thank you
okay so can you tell me more about how
it works I'm curious so okay so what you
said was that you know somebody who had
a situation where they signed their
money away in a certain way so that the
wife didn't get the money yes so maybe
what you didn't understand is that in
order to do that you would have to sign
a prenuptual agreement that is not the
default St that is not the default
outcome in a divorce system so in our
family law system here in the
UK everything the division of the assets
is assessed by the court and it's all
ruled ruled by legislation so when your
friend when or whoever that happened to
that was a case-by casee basis based on
a prenuptual agreement that they both
agreed to before they got married in the
family law system right now they will
take into account who earns what who
contributed what what assets they have
and that will be divided depending on
what they've done and what they've
contributed and what they haven't it's
so what you're saying is actually an
exception and it's also completely
different from the norm it's it's it's a
it's a contractual Contra though that's
what I was trying to say is still a
thing it's still a thing but what maybe
what you didn't understand is maybe that
it's just Case by case that's what
happened to them because they did a spec
they did a specific contractual
agreement before but for the majority of
people who don't do that that's not how
the law
works okay so I'm I'm curious who you're
the only one married right everyone else
no okay who here wants to be married
raise your
hand okay so one undecided okay and I'm
curious when would you guys want to be
married by so remind them what your age
is and when you'd want to be married um
yeah so you're all talking about like in
the I'm in my 30s 35 so um just I know
like too late forget
it um but um really sort of when I find
someone that I that I like so I did know
in the next few years whatever but it
has to be someone that I um that we
really like each other I just want to
get married just for the sake of it I'd
rather not if it's just what about kids
do you want kids I mean yeah if it's if
it's meant to be yeah I would if I if
I'm with a partner yeah okay are you
okay with not having them yeah whatever
will be will be yeah okay well I don't
understand that is isn't isn't it like
what you I've never really I've never
really been in a situation where I've
had to think about that because I would
only think about having a child with
someone if I'm really getting married to
someone in a situation like that so I'm
I've been I haven't had to worry or
think about it and it hasn't been
something I've grown up like oh I must
have kids I must be married by this age
I must be that I I've just like if I if
I find the one that I'm married to then
I would assume and want so if you I'm
just curious um how how much roughly do
you make a
year you don't have to give me like more
than more than 60,000 yeah okay more
than 70 yeah okay so you actually make
enough that you could retire by yourself
I mean not in London oh my God okay so
what's so what's your if the government
doesn't bail you out what's your plan if
you don't get married um
so my plan if I don't get married is
basically to have a property which I I
already do um but and then just just
explore the world and see what's going
on and just be happy but no I do I have
other things it depends on work well
yeah cuz it like let's say you live to
be 90 and like you can't really work
after like 65 so it's like what what do
you do for that 20 years if you don't
get married like most people need two
incomes to retire yeah you get into only
funds oh girl no one of only only 5% of
only F it's either prostitutes or only
fans are after like 40 45 you don't
really have that option you can I know a
woman that's like seven in she does yeah
lot of mils on there and stuff they're
not making the money you guys are making
I promise you also one um one of my um
jobs um they asked me if uh if I'm on
only fans cuz they were not going to
give me the job if I was on only fans
because it's um negative yeah negative
press and uh so yeah sex work now I
understand that but like actually that's
one point that I would like to to point
out so um in certain law firms that I've
worked at before when we are going
through people's um finances say for for
example if they're buying a property we
have to go through funds on the we when
we've got when we've had people that
they're getting their money through only
fans a lot of the time it can preclude
them from being able to go through with
the property sale because only fans is
potentially a high-risk um company and
there's also ties to child child porn
sex trafficking and things like that so
a lot of women don't know this but when
they go to buy a property and you're
asked okay what are your source of funds
what are your source of wealth and it
turns out that this is where your money
is coming from it's likely that you may
not be it depends on the law firm and
it's really up to them but you may not
be able to get a property because your
money is potentially coming from an
illegitimate place so there's the
potential for money laundering and you
know a law firm does not want to be
involved with any illegitimate source of
funds so something that you have to
consider yeah well I I was lucky to be
able to like buy outright so it wasn't
too much of a problem I mean obviously
it is like because you can't like easily
then snap up like 10 houses but I guess
then like buying outrights you know
you've paid for so but that's the thing
you're like the people who came to us at
that time they they were able to buy the
the properties outright but we had to
turn them away because our firm didn't
want to be associated with a company
that um promotes uh child exploitation
and sex trafficking yeah no it does come
with a lot of problems but you know I
recognize that and that's something I'm
willing to do and I just think I mean
it's it's good that you know that that
you're aware but I think a lot of girls
aren't aware and they don't think about
the future consequences of what could
happen to them and I think that it's sad
because it's like fast money fast
attention but it could really preclude
you from getting property in the future
and then possibly prude you from getting
married as well because men potentially
don't want to sleep well they probably
want to sleep with you but they probably
don't want to marry yeah no I there's a
lot of repercussions to do in only fans
and that's why I always stress if
someone wants to start it they should
think for it like thoroughly I thought
about it for like a year before I
actually did it and stuff like that but
I know obviously a lot of girls these
days are just kind of going into it
because they think it's going to be
quick easy money which you know it it
can be but it you know later on in life
then they come up with a lot of problems
yeah exactly um so how old are you 22
just okay and you said you wanted to be
married around 30 yeah well it depends
obviously like you said like I'm not
going to just settle like I um you can
get married at any age and at the end of
the day like it's a you know I'm only 22
so I've got a long life to live to spend
that with someone so I don't want to get
married too early what is what is
settling um being with someone that um
you don't NE neily like I don't know how
to explain it you're not necessarily
like really in love with or um you know
there's problems already in the
relationship okay so if there are
problems you're
settling yeah I don't know what the
right answer is do you think do you
think marriage comes with problems yeah
yeah no definitely but I mean as in like
um you know if you find a guy and you
you know you kind of like them but you
know you've had issues or something like
that do you think in marriage you're
always going to be mad in Love no no no
no I think I think marriage takes a lot
of hard work my parents spent through
counsel stuff like that so why is it
settling if if we have problems and you
aren't madly in love isn't that just
normal no I I think you should always be
in love with someone before you get
married to them do you do you think
there's not ups and downs in a
relationship no I don't disagree but I
mean as in like you know if there's red
flags from the start and um there's
little bits that already like annoy you
I wouldn't then want to get into a
relationship with someone for the next
50 years of your life do you think
you're annoying at all yeah yeah I don't
disagree so so isn't it kind of like
you're going to annoy each other at I
think I can find that person that like
isn't always annoyed at me I mean like
doesn't it just seems like this is based
a lot on feelings which like come and go
is that not what marriage is no no I I
think it's based on values I think and
you know character is very feelings so
what like being in love is very feelings
obviously what they tell us I think it's
a choice personally I think it's an
action I think you should definitely
have the same views on things cuz
obviously um you know you you want to
make sure that you're going to cooperate
like later on in life like you should
always have that conversation before
like how many kids you want or like this
or that and you don't want kids no so
why would a guy get married to you if
he's not going to get kids out of the
deal cuz he wants to live a long happy
life with me yeah but can he do that
without the marriage no but I I just
believe in marriage like um that you're
then like bonded to the person oh okay
so but marriage is traditionally Like a
Virgin yeah so you don't think it's like
like I'm just right right but but I'm
saying like if you believe in marriage
you know I don't you to be a virgin my
parents wen't a bloody virgin so I don't
think well we're going to go to
traditional marriage no I'm that mean
you can't get married I'm asking I'm
asking what he would get out of marri
marriage cuz you know you know with most
women most women you'll get kids right
so I'm asking like with you like what
but some men don't not ever wants kids
like men not all men want kids I I'm not
saying all men want kids but usually men
get married for kids yeah and not all of
them do as well but that's why we see
more men not getting married they have
60% or 70% of men under 30 aren't even
looking for relationships I mean that's
calm with them but I want to get married
and not have kids and I think I can find
some there's a like millions of people I
think you might I think you might
underestimate how difficult it's going
to be to find a guy you actually no no
no that you actually like it's not it's
easy to find anyone but that you
actually like to to get married because
the guys you like are going to have
options and they don't typically want to
marry women are be one only fans she's
really young yet she's not old enough to
know what she wants in the long in the
grand I'm not saying she's not
patronizing I'm not I'm not saying she's
not but my point is I'm asking like what
he would get out of marriage that he
wouldn't get out of a girlfriend look
why you keep saying like you need to get
like you talk strongly about marriage so
I don't understand why you trying to ask
her that like no I'm asking cuz she
wants to get married and I'm asking she
wants to like but I just want a nice
[__] wedding go on holiday it's so
interesting it's so interesting because
it's like you're kind of showing your
hand because I keep asking about what
the guy gets and you keep switching it
to what you want and I keep asking
because I'm asking you to think about
just wants to get
married wrong with a guy who just wants
to and I I'm I'm saying men can be with
you without being married yeah and they
to her as well so I'm just trying to do
a thought exercise where we think of
things from the men's point of view this
is this is just a clear example that
shows that women actually don't know
what men want and they don't care they
want a tight [__] but it shouldn't
always be conditional like oh I only
marry her because I want have kids out
of there you should actually have a
connection with her you shouldn't be
conditional until it's your conditions
that's what you want to see but it's it
should be about connection this is why a
lot of marriages don't work it's not
just because of the woman it's because
the man doesn't care about connection
they care more about oh what's her
reputation how many bodies has she got
it's ridiculous like that's why sne
never going to get married because he's
s that mindset sne will probably I will
keep proving the point you just keep
proving the point you don't know men you
don't know what men want even the men
that you said what they want but they
ain't going to get married still are
they you don't I'm I'm telling you and
you you I'm trying to even communicate
to you you're not even interested in
listening you don't care the way you're
sitting like you just don't care and
that's the fact it's the fact I know
what you want and the reality is the
reality is this is the problem that that
the Western and I say it specifically
the Western world is plagued with women
one don't have values they don't
understand what men want they don't care
what men want no you don't stud politics
it's not even a dig at you it's just
reality I'm just observing facts so
women don't understand values they don't
understand realities of life because
even when the other lady at the back was
trying to explain to you about what um
PR up the realities of prup and what um
things that could come up when you do
only you you kept bringing it back to
yourself because you actually are very
selfish and you think about only
yourself you don't even care about the
other women and I wanted to raise a
point this is this is a clear example
when men do things that are quote
unquote illegal or quote unquote bad for
society you would never see a man come
out in on a public platform to promote
it to other men but you always see women
come on platforms to promote silly
things promiscuous behaviors
toal it's not illegal point is if you
were to see a man that was selling drugs
and was probably making only fans in
selling drugs isn't the same thing no
I'm trying to make a point because if
you were to see a man that was probably
selling drugs or was into fraud or
whatever that makes his money like that
even if he promotes it as his lifestyle
you would never hear him say like oh
yeah I would advise my son to do that or
I advise my brother to do that men don't
do that because because we understand
because we understand that as a man
you're responsible for yourself and
you're responsible for your actions and
your actions have a direct repercussion
on you and the people that surround you
so you would always like to keep that to
yourself but I notice there a trend
among women that you actually don't care
maybe you don't care maybe you don't
know she did say earlier that she she
said that if she was a girl and she was
thinking about doing it to think about
it properly and for a long time she
never promoted okay that's like saying I
would think think long and hard before
you sell drugs said you both said that
you would your daughters to do only fans
no we didn't say that I did you did yeah
what problem with only fans it's not
illegal it's not harming anyone like
it's h it's better thaning her brain
though it's har why would you still like
promote her to do that though like if
she wants to she can people can do what
they want at we're not begging her to do
it all like saying oh do only but are
you going to say that like your life
like mentally is better yes I have a
good life like I enjoy my life I said
mentally you're not listening yes I I'm
I'm very mentally stable I've got great
mental health yes 100% I I honestly you
might say that but I beg to differ you
might not show it but and I can't get
into your body your brain I can't depict
it but like truthfully like I did only
fan so I can speak on this like that's
your perspective though it's not think
everyone issues and everyone has down
days it's quite normal I personally have
great mental health and I think a lot of
girls who actually enjoy it don't have
them like hon H you guys I see it all
the time act like that only only you act
like a fool like on the show the whole
time if you are so me I'm here to
promote my only fans I'm here to act
like a SL only only F workers are fine
they're fine when they're younger sort
of uh but it's like they I see them they
go crazy at like whenever they stop
being hot they just go absolutely ins be
that's when you hit the plastic that's
when it com timing so been on the
website before you start like losing
your look getting older what do you do
on it I'm I know that sounds really
stupid I know we've talked about only
fans for like forever but I actually
have never been on the website I
actually
don't know so I obviously it's all
levels like I personally do everything
so basically you subscribe and it's like
an Instagram kind of thing like that
kind of feed and then you know you can
pay more you can you can really World
your Royer you can do um like you do
like private chats you know you can do
facetimes you can do live streams like
it's really anything it's sex work so
where what were you saying completely
forgot I know yeah that's when you got
to time it like before you start maybe
losing your looks and everything so my
my more question was like what's your
plan for the second half of your life
because you need 2.5 wait okay please
don't inter I see it I see it okay um
you need 2.5 million to retire and your
plan is to get married but most guys
don't want to marry only fans workers
and so it's going to be difficult for
you yeah um so I I'm just curious if you
don't end up getting married what your
plan is for the second half of your life
well personally I already am um uh what
you like I own a own property and like
rent it out what is it called landlord
okay um so I already do that and
obviously I'd like to build on that with
my money like I don't just throw my
money away I invest it um what are you
invested in properties and like um
obviously so how many properties do you
have one currently okay and then an
apartment house yeah it's a house okay
and you you rent it out to like tenants
yeah yeah yeah okay and then I also like
invest in like Bitcoin my brother kind
of deals with it you know like online
stuff so you you at least have some plan
seems like um and then but to be fair
I've always said I'll do any fans until
I'm unhappy and I think that's going to
be a while from now and like like I said
like there's a Fage for anything like
people do want to see like old women and
old granny's I know it's not I'm not
look I'm not discounting that men will
pay for any type of sex but you are not
going to be making the same amount
amount of money and I think it's
disagree both okay do you do you all of
the top porn stars are under 30 and if
they are over 30 if they are older it's
because they built their following when
they were young and it's still they're
not over 40 porn's different to only
funds a lot different I I think it's
like the same thing it's not because on
only funds you can get to know like your
subscribers on a personal level and
that's why guys like to subscribe to
with they're just watching it it's not
speaking to someone Etc so I think it's
very different same gratification though
at the end goal is yeah but then they
can get to know the new 22y old yeah
yeah but not not all gu not all guys
fancy fresh [__] me you know sure
they'll they'll get to know the
40-year-old when you're 6 some guys some
guys have fetas for older women like I'm
curious what do you guys make a month on
only fans personally I don't like to say
same okay okay is it over six figures a
month yeah okay is it is it over six
figures I just said I'm not saying okay
fine um so did you you don't want to why
does every every time I come on a
podcast everyone always asks me asks
that question don't they because we want
to
know yeah it's it's enough it's not it's
I wouldn't do it if it wasn't enough
like she charges more than she does per
month the brunette charges more than the
blonde per month so if she's working six
figure she's got to be in it more
logically but it depends on like
following and stuff like that and like
obviously you do a little bit less don't
you and stuff like that it just depends
um but I mean I don't fist my [__]
but if you want to see that
subscribe she gave me a tutorial on how
to do it she starts with one finger then
two then three then four and then the
whole fist go in wow did you you said
you didn't want to be married right me
yeah I don't really mind if I like the
thing is like if I meet someone and like
I feel like it's the right thing to do
then yeah I'd get married but if not
like I don't really think marriage is
like really that important to be fair
like I'm just curious what your plan is
for your life so you want to do only
fans till no I've got plans uh I invest
my money into other things so I mean I
actually got my life set out I might
seem really dumb on this podcast but I'm
actually very smart and everyone tells
me that so but yeah you guys might think
I'm dumb I can see you laughing in the
back but I'm actually quite a smart girl
like Who's
Laughing the law the lawyer or whatever
she is
yeah okay so so what's your plan so
you're invested in what like stocks
Bitcoin I don't really need to share
what I do what I'm invested in I've got
my life plan out it's not really
anything for you to worry about I'm not
worried I'm just curious I just I don't
know why this is like a secret like it's
notr I'm not asking I I didn't make you
say how much you made I'm just curious
what your plan is cuz I meet so many
only fans workers so I'm just curious
yeah I think a lot of only fans go like
they get a lot of money and like they
don't like spend it wisely and then they
see all their money disappear and it's I
just think like if you do only fanss you
have to be smart about it as well
because you need to invest your money in
other things and you need to realize
that when you you are older you might
not be able to get a normal job like
other people say because of what you've
done before you need to would you guys
be okay if only fans got banned tomorrow
yeah because there's other platforms
yeah I mean I would I would I definitely
would make what if they started cracking
down they're try go to the streets okay
so you'd become a hooker yeah wow okay
what about you that's that oh pass your
judgment on Jus I can hear wow it's not
judgment it's just you know what that
was can I tell you what that that was
shock I was literally shocked to hear no
I think that's what most I kind of
expected that like what else what else
what else are you going to do like I
actually think there's a difference
between only fans and prostitution again
I don't do it and never have part
talking it but again selling an image of
yourself to you know talking to talking
to the mic sorry presenting yourself in
an image in a certain kind of way is
very different to spend your legs and
getting paid by random to you I mean
that's very different like you've got to
be a certain kind of woman to number one
do that number one to take deal with a
mental stability the fact you've had
Lads of random men coming in you because
that's what it is that's not I do that
the weekend anyway yeah but have some
self-respect hun like be better than
that I think you want to do it go for it
yeah just think do what you want in your
life like I don't need Jud from you guys
it's not it's notal like prostitution is
not legal yes it is please
educ es prti very escorting in
prostitution very difference escorting
is paying for your time sex is optional
defit i' definitely just go more into
the sex work wait what escorting isn't
sex escorting is you know spending time
with you whether or not you choose have
sex and that is your decision speak to
sorry escorting sorry having spending
time with someone is your decision
that's where they're paying for your
time you choos to have sex with them
okay you choose to have sex and that's
that's your decision that is what Border
Lines prostit so if you're set in sex
you spreading your legs and you're
getting paid for it that is prostitution
that is illegal and also do
better what chill a Jesus no no no
honestly no
PR prostition isn't illegal H H you're
telling me your parents will be fine
with spr legs I'm men come inside you
yes no they would but they don't love
you enough I'm they use a Johnny though
when you have prostitution sex I guess
honestly there's no morals or boundaries
or St back in this room it's shocking
like as a woman as a woman 32y old if my
daughter said that same not that
shocking but for me it is it's shocking
that's for me
that's like yeah I know this is
normalized unfortunately especially in
America you know I think they just
wanting to get paid now I get
it why would I not do it for I get I get
you want to get paid but there is there
not a
l the money I just I I love sex like
I've always want
be she did say she was
super I'm going to I'm I'm going to go
to the next one I'm GNA go to next one
okay do you want to be married what me
yeah uh yeah okay what age how old are
you you're you're 19 years old oh you're
only 19 shocking isn't it wait and you
said you're on you're on sugar daddy
sites or something is that what you said
yes now I'm just curious how many sugar
daddies do you have is it one or is it
like multiple uh probably about three or
four consistent monthly allowances and
do you do you have to like do sex stuff
with all of them or how does it work
it's an option yeah it's an option yeah
they don't all like want me to have sex
with well they probably do want me to
have sex with them but I don't all have
sex with them so okay how many do you
sleep with at a time oh she just say she
doesn't do it no she said she doesn't
she have to but of course she does I
don't unless they're Lang which I do
like old men with gray hair to be
fair or Arabs I find Arabs sexy as well
no I'm just I'm just kind of curious how
it works so how much do they send you a
month well I've only been doing it for
two three months
but I mean I've only got what two
consistents two more potentials but over
15K did you see that do by party W so
you get but I don't I do you have like
line of like something you won't do do
you buy Port poy I don't do that to be I
would if it was enough money if it was
enough money I to buy P actually I'm
curious what is what is like a line for
you three is there anything you wouldn't
do for money you won't [__] for money I
asked her actually because basically we
were having this conversation I got
offered like a lot of money to sleep
with a guy and I said no Lily said she
would do it but like I wouldn't do that
person because like I I don't I feel
like I would feel really horrible after
and like I feel like it would have a lot
like a really big effect on my mental
health and like I don't really sleep
with guys anyway so I wouldn't really
sleep with a guy for money because like
I don't know like I feel like to have
sex with someone you've got to kind of
like have like a connection with them
and I just feel like sleeping with
someone that you don't have a connection
with and a random person like I just
think it's a bit weird um okay so you
won't do sex for money not prostition no
I don't do a I I don't really like the
thing is that I have a limit like I
don't do everything um but
like um yeah some obviously some girls
can like do it but I just wouldn't do it
okay um and for you the if the price is
high enough you'll you'll oh yeah I'll
get shoted on if it was like I would
probably get my shot on yeah for like
see no I wouldn't do the [__] thing yeah
see she she would rather have a
c see I didn't get that like I want to
know like would you rather have someone
[__] on your chest I think loads of men
would do that for 50k Plus I don't
disagree with you um okay okay so you
want to do the sugaring thing for how
long and long enough till I've saved to
buy assets I guess maybe okay so how
much do you want to
save 100 200k okay and are you on on
track are you saving most of it yeah to
be fair yeah okay I've would done it for
like three months so what 200k that's
like two I can't do math like three
years maybe two three years anyone do
math no
it's women in the room you know what I
mean um okay and then when do you when
do you want to be married um before I'm
25 okay so I already know she's going to
marry richm it doesn't matter how much
she
makes she's going to marry an old
gray what made you go down the only fans
route why didn't you or sorry sugar it's
all the same to me the the sex the sex
work route instead of you know sex
worker I mean what else all sex work
isn't it it's all sex worker um person I
personally I actually don't think
there's a difference between only fans
and prostitution I'm not saying I'm
prostitute because I'm not but um I
think it's the same thing because Tech I
think most girls only fans don't just do
it because of the money I think most of
them do it because they do like
attention as well male attention I don't
think there's anything wrong with that
but I do think most only fans girls
don't do it just for the money I think
that's ridiculous look at Anna for
example Anna Paul could be making
millions from Tik Tok but she chooses to
do any fans because they like the
attention as well and um but personally
I think women that do the sugar Day
stuff they literally just do it for the
money um I don't really care about the
attention from old man to I don't I I
disagree CU I think like um prostitution
is very different to only fans like I
think having like causes the same
destruction in society though the same
the same bad effects of society it
causes the same thing men to cheat on
their wives and pay for sex pay for you
can't sh On Your Wife by only fans you
Che your no you can't well so you think
subscribing to a girl only fans isn't is
it you would be okay with your h no I'm
not saying it would be okay but it's
technically not chea cheating is putting
a dick in El I think it's the same thing
it's Hest loyal I think okay actually
I'm curious because this is going to be
a
question if I found out I was dating
someone and he was spending like let's
say a good chunk of change on an only
fans chick like two I think I'd rather
have him [__] I would rather have [__]
go in real life at least he can get
girls yeah think I would I think like
finding out if he SP I mean if it was
like five bucks a month okay but I'm
like if he spent good money I think I
would pick all right so who so I'm just
I want to raise a hands I'm just curious
He Cheats would you rather have cheat sh
can you wait for me to do the hands can
you thank you all right so option one is
he SL he spent you found out he spent
two grand on an only fans chick option
two is he slept with another chick one
time when he was drunk who picks option
one oh God who picks option two wow
telling but can you ask the question
telling can you ask the question would
you rather your daughter do only fans or
would you rather your daughter be a
prostitute there is a difference cuz
it's physical right one is physical like
one's better for the guy and one's
better for the girl so it's kind of like
the guy the girl can still be Hing
around doing physic but I think I think
the point it's all the same category to
regular people it's work yeah I disagree
strongly I mean you could disagree but
I'm telling you how the world some fans
I agree again it's borderline isn't it
yeah I mean it's it's slightly better
but it's like all the same to me the
difference is you getting money of it
whereas the people in porn don't get the
money it's the directors the producers
who get that money so again you're the
smarter ones out of that kind of
scenario yeah cuz I mean I I don't porn
porn stars don't actually make that much
money now they used to but they don't
now only fans yeah because of only fans
so readily available everywhere yeah and
okay I'm curious when do you want to get
married I'm not even sure if I want to
get married okay I don't like the
language of marriage uh so um what would
your ideal situation
be hang out with a lot of chicks okay
single and just running through
chicks when when I've had enough is it
just like what about a kid you want one
or n ye I mean no not really no I'm not
even sure like no no I think a lot of
guys feel this way to be honest yeah to
look after a kid that's just like such a
how old are you 41 really You' aged
really well wow thanks I don't even
think B age like that wants to [__] you
now
what all right um all right what about
you um your age and when you want to get
married I'm 32 I wanted to get married
when I was like 25 okay and what do you
what do you felt like stopped you from
getting married um just circumstantial
just you've got to be with someone who's
compatible who share the same values and
morals basically and if you're not with
that person you're not going to make
that commitment so why weren't you with
that person I was oh I was and I wasn't
at the same time again we just decided
we're very different people okay who
decided that him or you me okay so you
decided you were diff What was two
different
um I just decided that I was a different
person and wanted different things I
suppose okay so like he wanted to get
married and you didn't no he proposed I
just decided not to get married to that
particular person was it just I'm just
curious like what it was about him was
it like a feeling or uh got Feeling Just
circumstantial like we worked in a very
similar place he put himself in
situation where I wouldn't put myself
nor expect my fiance or future husband
to put them what kind of situation going
on nights up and the arms around girls
buying them drinks that's not my man if
my man is with me my man is with me I'm
like a man I don't sh do you think so
I'm I'm just just curious if you ended
up not getting married would you regret
that decision no okay so I'd rather live
my my life happily than with a man
unhappily and settling for Less because
again regardless if you're a man or
woman you deserve a certain you know
certain I I think you kind of get what
you deserve yeah I don't yeah I don't
think there's like you deserve anything
yeah you get what do with so you're 32
um and you want to be married as soon as
possible do you want kids I want yes
okay how many kids do you want depends
whatever will come my way okay do you
feel like pressure being 32 and not
married um no again I I I feel the same
amount of pressure my parents I did when
I was 22 I think my parents come from a
generation where they think that you
should be 16 married with the kids and
move on okay whereas again it's a dral
thing and how would you feel if you
never got married I'm okay with it okay
you're you're fine what's your what's
your plan for the second half of your
life [__] Wing
It wing it like take every day it comes
because not every day is guaranteed
right but it you still you need 2.5
million to retire are you on track for
that no no absolutely not most most
people in this generation AR I'm okay
with work every day I know but my
question is more like what happens
because like let's say someday the
government might stop giving people free
money and it at some I've never lived
off benefits in my life I'm not I'm not
saying you did but I'm saying a lot of
women are on track too because we're not
making enough and we're not going to be
able to work like we used to
work so like you're going to be like cuz
a lot of of us make money off of beauty
and we don't realize that so it's like
you're going to be 65 it's a Walmart
greeter oh you can work in a cool sent
he doesn't matter if you're [__] ugly or
not you can work at a call center it
makes no difference exact we know you
can work at a call center my point is
that these aren't typically desirable
High income jobs but you don't have to
have that you don't not every person
spies to have 10 million pound in the
bank some people just want to my point
is I I think you underestimate how
difficult it's going to be to work
full-time at an old age what if what if
you get cancer what if you're sick you
know especially like with the choices um
and the food and the water like a lot of
us are going to have health issues right
so you know what happens if the
government doesn't bail us out again if
you don't and my my general consensus is
no one has a real plan no if you don't
have a choice if you don't have a plan
you just get out and work if that's your
only option you get out and work if
that's the only way you going able to
make money why would you not do it well
I I think there's going to be a lot of
women that are homeless yeah or men no
because why would men not have the same
kind of issue as women would well the if
women if the difference is the
difference is like women get don't
typically or women always typically get
bailed out so there's always a woman's
shelter or benefits you can get if you
get divorced you can take his money and
my question is what would happen if the
system changed where men typically have
to face reality there's no men's
shelters waiting to bail them out um
some men are on benefits but it's not
the majority it's the majority women on
benefits so my question is one day if
the government stops bailing us out if
men stop bailing us out and we can't
make money on beauty like we used to
what are we going to do
work work the crazy thing is women are
so readily um they so ready to take on
that risk of doing life on their own
with all these crazy things you've said
but they wouldn't take that risk with a
man that's crazy to me that's actually
tapped like it's it's like putting the
cut before the horse it's like you're
not even thinking
about and it's like you said women don't
like a lot of women don't think about
the future they think about now and
what's happening right around around
them especially these young ones they
think oh I'm beautiful I'm always going
to be beautiful the reality is you might
say that now but you actually don't know
what your 30s is going to be like you
don't know what you're going to look
like when you're 30 you don't know what
you're going to look like when you're 35
you might be getting all the attention
from men now you actually don't know how
soon that's going to change you you're
believing that it's going to stay
this or that you don't know if you're
going to fall sick you're not going to
be a to do your only fans anym you have
idea of these things but you would still
you're still willing to take that risk
on your own than to actually look for a
man and take and do life with him I mean
well if if you lived your whole life in
fear of you know what's going to happen
tomorrow then you may as well I mean it
doesn't have to be fear but you know
maybe I think us women would benefit
more with a little bit of planning I'll
give you
I'll give you an example okay this kind
of has to do with that you know I think
my life probably wouldn't have been
better if I didn't chase I chased a
volleyball career for like my early 20s
and it's stupid it doesn't even make
money you make like negative money
playing volleyball and you know I think
in general women we could you know do a
little more planning in
general um all right what when do you
want to get
married
uh when I meet
somebody that I'm in love with I I came
close to marrying somebody okay what
happened and I was pretty heartbroken
for a while so I was quite anti marriage
and now I'm kind of what what happened
why didn't you marry him um
because well he was from Saudi Arabia so
it was had quite different ideologies
slightly
um
about male and female roles I guess in
oh you didn't want to play your role
it's slightly different it's not really
what's the what's the role of a
wife things that um slightly different
in uh marriages was guess in um I I can
understand that but I'm trying to
understand like what was
different um I think it was probably on
maybe sometimes On The Other Extreme too
much where females
can't um have any voice or be able to do
anything for themselves at all too much
and also what were you not allowed to do
it's I just it just wasn't right for me
so I just don't I just I didn't see it
working yeah as opposed to the Western
ideology where wom control the thing is
that there was but you do realize that
in the west women actually like it's
actually the reverse so what what you're
talking about in Saudi Arabia in the
west is the reverse so women it's
completely different yeah yeah yeah the
extremities are so so knowing that you
guys had different values what made you
date him in the first place was he hot
well no it wasn't it's complex I don't
know it's not that complic like what was
it give me like three things that made
you date
him your values were so different like
what were you
doing well I think some of our values
were the same um okay so then why didn't
you marry
him because because I wanted to have a
bit more of my own life as well like I
didn't want to just be in the shadow of
being just with a guy okay you don't
think that's a plus to be with a guy of
course you're just saying it as a
negative that's why I'm asking because
it felt like a negative yeah like I you
don't want to just be with a guy and
that's that's your own existence I just
found that a little bit when you're
married do you think your identity is
supposed to be in yourself or your
family both you can have your own IND
idual identity and be a have a family
unit okay do you think it works that way
the more individual identity women have
had the better outcomes we've
had I think it depends on how the levels
of it you know you don't want to be like
the thing is when when you sometimes
when couples get together you can be so
too much about the other person and then
you lose yourself and you don't know
your your own self that's a really like
feminine point of view because we hate
when guys are too into us
men like it yeah if they if they
actually like you they're into that they
there's no you're too into me if you're
hot enough if you're kind of ugly
they're not put nothing with that yeah
Beyonce did a number on on women so
women have this like they think they
want to be like Beyonce where the man is
important and the woman is important but
if you look at the reality of the world
the kind of men you want go and look at
all their wives who knows like LeBron
James wife look at that um look at the
most important people Cristiano Ronaldo
look at um um the president nobody knows
their wife they just know them as the
first lady so the reality is if you want
a certain kind of man you're more than
likely not going to be as important as
him that's the fact yeah and I can speak
on that myself like being a married
woman I think that there is this notion
in society where women want to be at the
Forefront women want to have the say
they want to be able to control their
man and for me like with my husband he
is the leader of our relationship he he
leads he provides he protects and I I'm
definitely the fan he's the celebrity
that's the dynamic that works and I
think that that's what we are missing in
our society now because it's just like
the women want to be at the they want
all the attention like who is it um
Curry Steph Curry oh yeah came out and
was like I don't get attention from guys
and it's like you're married to one of
the most powerful like well-respected
Sportsmen and you're worried about why
people don't give you attention
and Cur AA
Curry think basketball right I don't
know I don't know much about sport well
I think we've been we've been told that
like we're so important for so long that
we just have this propaganda saying that
you shouldn't lose anything in marriage
and and the truth is not important and
the truth is you're supposed to lose
part of your identity you interrupt a
lot you know I'm sorry but I just I just
I felt quite strongly about that I know
what if you feel what if you you told
the opposite or if you thought the
opposite that you're not important like
that comes you're not that you're not
that important I just don't understand
why we have this Society where you're so
special most people are average most
people aren't that important yeah um and
I think the family is important I think
that's what it's supposed to be the
family is more important than you as a
whole exactly and also like if you look
at how a dynamic in a relationship works
if you're both trying to be the boss
you're both trying to be the CEO you're
both trying to take control of the
relationship and Lead it there's going
to be conflict like and there and
there's this notion with feminism now
that a woman being under a man is
something that's so detrimental to us
when actually having a man to to lead
you and that doesn't mean that you're
his slave like I think this negative
notion that feminism has has sold us is
really sad because at the end of the day
if you choose a good partner if you vet
a guy and you make sure that he is going
to be a good leader he has all the right
qualities then you don't have to see
yourself as second class like my
husband's a leader but we discuss things
he comes to me for my opinion he
respects me so so so so much the same
way that I do and it doesn't mean that
I'm lesser than him it just means that I
accept my role and I I nurture him I
make sure that I keep the house tidy I
cook I clean I bake I do absolutely
everything and I work as well but I know
that that's what makes our relationship
work well and I'm not trying to fight
with him I'm not trying to be the leader
I know he's the leader and that creates
Harmony in our home I think that's
beautiful like if you've got a healthy
marriage and a healthy relationship like
I'm all for it I think that's great I
just don't think I was was that's why
wasn't but I'm just saying now I'm still
open to marriage just that one didn't
work I'm curious who taught you
that uh he did really yeah I was
actually bloop pill before Oh my God I
used to where was he from he's a
Nigerian oh okay I was
like he's over there okay I was like it
can't be here you didn't learn that
either but no but he grew up there I
mean he came here when he was seven so
but he has you know he has his identity
in his in his Nigerian Heritage but then
also his British culture but I was very
brainwashed by feminism I believed in
you know all of all of the things that
people tell us nowadays I loved Beyonce
I was completely Beyonce is a Beyonce
says one thing and does another thing
Beyonce tells women that they should be
independent get on to the next man all
the single ladies she's married she
settled down with Jay-Z he cheated on
her and she still stayed with him so
clearly all of the feminist stuff that
she speaks about is not actually how
living her life so she stay with him for
the for the children though at the end
of the day she speak being an
independent woman but she still stayed
so her family came first and her
marriage came first so she's saying one
thing and doing another and she's
contradict you know I think it's just a
song though would you stay with your man
if
he yes I would because like Paul said
like there's so much more you would stay
with your man if he cheated on you if we
could work it out yes fair enough
whatever whatever you just said is why
he just go cheat then why does it why
why is it irrelevant it's ridiculous cuz
why would you be submissive why would
you be submissive to a man that's not
even going to care about your feelings
or but this is the thing like you you
are saying that he's not caring about my
feelings obviously like you just didn't
hear anything we said about the male
biology about the sperm like I live in
reality so I know that something might
happen and I'm not going to let that
break down my entire life and my you
know my entire relationship obviously we
have to work on things we have to to
speak about things but to me it's not
the end of the world like Paul said it's
not the end of the world but do you
expect it do I expect do you expect it
to happen because because you've given
him all the excuses do you expect it I'm
just curious I'm just living in reality
if it it's likely that it would happen
it doesn't mean it doesn't mean she
expects it it's not
embarrassing I mean you're a sugar baby
who are you to call you're just like
okay my husband's allowed to cheat on me
he's just listening
right no she she didn't say he's allow
out we work out
at the end of the day do you remember do
you okay the vows richer for poor and
sick the is the vows to be loyal though
is that not one of the main vows no it's
not there's noow what the point ofs then
the point of The Vow is you make a
commitment what does red pill blue pill
mean so red pill is basically what Pearl
does so she talks about reality she
talks about men and women relationships
and blue pillar is like when everybody
else just lives in delusion and they
think men can sleep around like women
sorry women can sleep around like men
can men and women are equal the gender
pay Gap all these lies that Society has
told us all the propaganda that's blue
pill and that's where most people live
and then red pill is the truth and
that's basically what P show them
because like I don't really
like the
exception delusion you're you're
definitely blue we're like orange
right bro what
you guys are just very immature then I
was asking a serious question I think
that you're immature like
you whole show you just want the BBC you
don't want a lawy just want the
BBC don't tell me what I want and don't
don't disrespect me don't disrespect my
husband like just shut your mouth who me
oh sorry whoever said that whoever said
you just want BBC you have no idea what
a real relationship is you you don't
mind being cheated on love I said no
don't misquote me I said that I know the
realities of men I know the biological
realities and I'm not going to let it
break down my family if it were to
happen so you're going to let it happen
I feel like it's just a long word Don't
Be Misunderstood it is a free pass
really she said she understands reality
of men doesn't mean she didn't vet her
man course going to be on our side mate
it's not about being on side you don't
vet men before you sleep with them
doesn't mean that everyone does the same
thing ex but I do believe that if like a
guy cheats is a little bit different
like cuz they don't have feelings and
stuff so that's the red pill but then I
also believe why are you pulling that
face gosh it's like you just bit a lemon
because you because of what you just
said cuz it's stupid what so it's
different for a guy men don't have
feelings that's not true that's no I I'm
saying that it's different for a guy to
cheat because they don't they can just
stick their dick in anything and like
they can't like exactly so then why
break up a whole family over it but I
don't care about that part what I'm say
so but you just call me stupid for
saying that you said that men don't have
feelings that's yeah they don't really
have feelings when they [__] girls cuz
they can just [__] anything and just
like so you're saying that if you're
saying it's okay for your husband to
cheat you but then you're saying I never
said it was okay for him to cheat said
understand reality I I said that I
understand are you guys wait wait I'm
just are you guys stupid or deff um bir
all right all right I'm going to sorry
what were you saying so I'm going to ask
you is it okay for your husband to cheat
do you encourage it no I don't okay but
you let it happen no let iten tell Fu
you would gosh if it happens think'll be
just more understanding it should it
happened is that what you're saying
saying she's g a free no that's not what
I'm saying I'm saying that I think that
this notion of cheating is just it's
just a feminist ideology to break down
the family because at the end of the day
back in the day people were polyamorous
men had or polygamous anyway men had
multiple wives and if you go to Saudi
Arabia and and and parts of Africa and
lots of parts in the world so it's not
the end of the world and if you live
reality you will know that and you'll
probably have a better life because you
can just accept the reality and you're
not going to let something stupid like
that break down your whole family that's
my point would you let him have another
wife bro y' are so like it's do you know
what it's not about me like you guys
don't even listen anyway so I'm not even
going to answer your I'm not even going
to can't argue with
stupid would you so you know you guys
also
say um you also say like oh um you talk
about like how women cheat more than men
men cheat more than women and like how
nowadays like it's all changed back in
the old days like we didn't even used to
have like mobile phones to communicate
and like know that someone was cheating
on us so like the stats probably would
have been a lot different back then had
we have known because every everything
everything gets posted on social media
nowadays you go through people's phones
you find them cheating Etc so how would
you even I think we can have I think we
can have some indication when you look
at pictures of today and you have wives
dressed like [__] and you look at
pictures of a hundred years ago and
they're covered because you wear a dress
and just because you wear a skirt like
doesn't mean that you're you're more
likely okay who do you think's more
likely to be a [__] the person wait
wait wait wait sh that's not relating to
what I just said stop stop stop stop no
no I didn't even finish the qu who's
more likely to be a [__] someone
dressed like a [__] or someone not
dressed like a
[__] in general please
right now but you see these are the
these are the games women play because
it's just like Dave Chappelle said if
you were walking down the street and
someone robbed you and then you saw a
man standing down the road wearing a
police uniform and you ran up to him and
we like oh my god um excuse me officer
can you help me and he was like oh just
because I'm dressed like a police
officer doesn't make me a police officer
this is the stupid games that women play
exactly just because yes if you're
dressed like a [__] and you and you and
you claim you're not a [__] it doesn't
matter you're still going to be treated
like one that's why they say dress as
you want to be addressed yes it's simple
I don't really care about that to be
honest like if you want to get your ti
out what I'm trying to say no what I'm
trying to say is that back then we used
to have to like call someone on our
house phone why you taking your
headphones off stop being rude like I'm
talking you know what I mean listen to
what I'm saying babe if I take the
headphones off I can still hear you you
know that right okay good my mouth's big
get over it you sound [__] what I'm
trying to say is D sound [__] for
saying that okay anyway what I'm trying
to
say no you guys are listening cuz you
you like trying to because you don't
want to hear what I'm saying because I'm
arguing arguing with him let's let's sh
I'm anyone let all right we're going to
let her I'm going to give you the floor
go ahead okay what I'm trying to say is
that when like maybe like I don't know
how many years ago to meet up with
someone you have to like call their
house phone and then go and meet up with
the person so how would you even know if
someone's cheating or whatever like back
then because you don't have the
technology today to know like you have
more technology now to know that
someone's cheating ex and like it's just
like these days and these stats like it
just shows that you wouldn't have known
if someone was cheating on you back then
like you would know now okay so you
think the women dressed like
[__] I let you I let you talk I let
you talk it's it's your turn to listen
All right so you think the women today
dressed like [__] cheat equally as
much as the women 100 years ago not
dressed like [__] that got married
about a decade earlier I'm not saying
that no what I'm okay so so wait wait
wait so who do you think cheated more
the women of today or the women of
yesterday of a hundred years
ago well I don't know that no pick one I
don't know pick a guess I don't know
okay well then I think maybe you need to
think a little bit and come back the
point you made was valid I get it's more
documented nowadays you've got more
accessibility to kind of see who do you
think cheated more we're going to% okay
so then why are like I just don't
understand I don't understand this like
I I I don't understand what like this is
a woman thing like if I say water is wet
men don't really argue do you see any of
the guys arguing with this but women
will nitpick well that's not true
entirely there's except we know there's
exceptions we know okay when do you want
to be married like literally anytime
possible you want to marry your
boyfriend I do what how long have you
guys been together we literally I know
it sounds crazy we literally been dating
for like 2 weeks what but why do you
want to settle down so quickly would you
he proposed that's just how I was raised
um I was raised very old school and
you've got your whole life to be with
someone do you see how okay I have a
question I'm just gonna point this out
do you see how like misery loves
company like I'm just no I'm just
demonstrating because the the married
women did not say Hey you have your
whole life but the only fans worker says
you have your whole life ahead why would
you want to marry someone when you've
been dating them for two weeks like
that's delusional people used to do that
all the time it's not delusional though
because it's like it's a feeling like if
you feel it you know it like and if I
choose to get married tomorrow that's my
life just like how I said it's your life
and you could pop your [__] on the
internet if you want to go ahead if I
choose to get married there's nothing
wrong with that I'm not affecting anyone
I'm not hurting anyone I'm not like have
you told him does he know no yeah he
knows we're both on the same page about
it can I I was speaking I was actually
still talking to her like how before you
know how you said it's a beautiful thing
like how her marriage is like you see I
respect you for that because a lot of
like other women today like how she
lives her life and how she's married she
gets [__] on for that but then people
like you don't get [__] on right
majority of the time we get sh on we've
been getting [__] on the whole Fu of
course but there's still like majority
of the people aren't going to [__] on
you for you doing only fans no they do
definitely it's all about girl power
today let's be [__] for real you just
said you make you just you just said you
make six figures a month isn't that like
compensation for the [__] oh I I don't
care about the hate cuz I've got like
really good care and mimicking me is
like super low so and I think you're
rude to be honest I'm not being rude I'm
just being straight up with you you know
mimicking someone is rude right okay I I
don't care so then if how are you going
to call me rude and then you're rude as
well like how are you going to call her
rude when you just went talking about
someone's husband when the husband is
literally sitting right there I was I
didn't say that it was someone else bro
um I have a question two weeks um would
you well like we've been talking
obviously for a while but like for
everything is like obviously official
but yeah go ahead but how long are you
actually you think you both going to get
engaged like give no like not like
tomorrow obviously like we're going
today for a while but like it's my dream
to get married young that's what I want
like I don't want to wait till I'm 30 to
have kids and do [__] like that like
rather do that now at a young age and
just get out of the way I feel like I
have more energy now to deal with
children I'm a nanny as well like I take
care of people's kids for living and you
know to be a nanny you really genuinely
have to love children to do it I was
also a dance teacher so I've always
worked with kids and it's just like I
feel like that's what my calling is I
feel like that's what women are meant to
do and yeah people may be like oh you're
[__] crazy cuz you're young and I I
really don't care how old are you again
I just turned 23 like 3 months my mom
had me 23 yeah that's that's yeah so my
mom had me at 23 as well but it was out
of wedlock and this is what I was trying
to say before like my parents have been
separated on and off my whole entire
life got divorced when I was 12 so like
honestly people think it's crazy that
I'm very like you know red pill and
conservative and stuff like that because
of how my upbringing was as well but
like honestly it's an example of like
what I don't want to do what my parents
did so well and it's unfortunate because
I just think that we don't really have
places to learn from because h ly the
generation before us really was not
taught to submit to their husbands and I
think it caused I mean I don't know what
their problems were but I think the
mindset of equality really caused a lot
of issues because you can't have two
kings of a household someone's got to
lead doesn't work it does it doesn't
work isn't it about balance though
because it just seems so extreme talk
about such extreme views this is this is
just my view right so I just see what
worked and a hundred years ago when
women believed in submitting and serving
their husband that worked and the more
we try this equality being equal like I
just see women trying to control men
that that's what I keep seeing and I
think it doesn't work and I think it's
evil and a lot of men live their lives
with nagging wives and just are bending
to her will for a lifetime and you know
I I just think it's sad I don't think
I'd want to live my life like that happy
wife happy life if you submit to a man
is it okay for them to then control you
yeah it is yes that's the that's the
point controlling though in such a bad
way like it's really not cuz like look
at her do you like you look at her you
think she's in a toxic ass marriage
miserable crying herself to sleep every
night no because when you do submit to
your man and your man is leading and
protecting and providing everything
naturally falls into place exactly but I
think that sounds healthy compared to
control I don't think control sounds he
it's like she said like control doesn't
have to be negative it's just like
there's order do you know what I'm
saying okay does your boss control
you um if he gives you an order you
listen right no always okay you're an
only fans that doesn't count but when I
do have a job cuz I actually had very
normal I'm not ask not asking you not
I'm asking her when you when know your
boss gives you an order you listen right
yeah so it's interesting because we'll
listen to people that give us money but
we won't listen to the father of our
kids isn't that kind of backwards who
loves you I I kind of get what I do get
what you're saying I just I just I think
maybe it's just a choice of words of how
you say it you should still listen to
the the mother as kids though no I don't
think I think CU women again we've
proven this whole show that women really
aren't the smartest and we don't make
great
decisions and I and I look I just look
at the last hundred years okay and I
look at what's worked and what hasn't
worked and the truth of the matter is
when women get more power and control
we're not very nice with it we tend to
break up our family am we tend to spend
too much money um we we get into a bunch
of debt yeah we get promis my mom has
taught me that my whole life feelings
are not facts and and I think and that's
what we live off of yeah and I think
they've lied to us cuz they've told us
we can be men and we can't my is the
houses in the relationship I guessed
that actually I guess that that's that's
oh there relationship leave them out of
there no no but that's the point is you
said which you I'm not even trying to be
funny you literally said your mom
encouraged you to do only fans yeah and
if your father wore the pants in the
family that would never fly oh Dad
doesn't mind either I am interested he
doesn't mind because your mom wears the
pants that's the point some parents love
their kids
unconditionally if they did they
wouldn't encourage I am interested cuz
your point of
view so I see I see so I you know what's
funny I knew that about her because I've
done so many of these interviews she
didn't even have to say it because
whenever you see a household that's
super out of order typically the woman
is imposing her will on the man because
women typically because women I mean you
can't be in order if she's doing only
fans right um can you mute their mics
because they just keep interrupting um
so so typically I just think the natural
order of the world is God men women
children and it sounds extreme when you
first hear it but right now we have a
society where men and women have been
told we're equal right and we have an
equal say you just have to find a
balance Etc whatever and issue with that
is ever since we've gotten power what's
happened we've left our husbands we've
gotten into all this debt we've gone on
only fans all this [__] right so that
tells me women we don't make wise
decisions on our own but we've been told
that we do and we really don't we've
been told that we're smarter and we're
really not and I think that leaves us to
live in delusion when I think you're
supposed to trust the guy you have kids
with to follow his judgment if you were
at work and every time your boss wanted
to make a decision you argued that would
never
work right so we'll give the best of us
to our boss but but we won't give it to
the person we're having a family with
it's
backwards but then okay yeah no I I
don't disagree with what you're saying I
think it's interesting if you were the
right man yeah yeah I was going to say
that first of all finding the right man
right for starts yeah who's going to do
this amazing leading yeah for the family
yeah that's very difficult in the modern
age right from the beginning what you
said about finding that I'll tell I'll
tell you the problem though so women we
find 80% of men as ugly not okay not
unattractive but ugly that's why I know
we're all sleeping with the same guys
cuz women find them all ugly the
difference was before you didn't have
access to the hottest guys you didn't
have access to the celebrities you
didn't have access to doesn't even have
to be celebrities but just the hot guys
on social media dating apps Instagram
right so you know all the hottest guys
would go get married and then you know
the okay looking guy would kind of make
you laugh and you fall in love and like
the guy down the street that's kind of
how it would happen right because we can
Builder attraction in other ways but the
issue is women mate select for looks
typically in their 20s and then in their
30s it switches more to long-term and
like resources typically and so the
issue we get is like you know we get to
30 we've slept around with all these
people and then we're less valuable to
the guy that was really on our level 10
years ago but we just have an inflated
sense of ego because you know it's like
the men being addicted to porn we are
addicted to social media it changes our
whole worldview and nobody can convince
me otherwise because just hear girls
coming in with the same arguments that
are just regurgitated on social media um
and again I think that's what happens
when the media is female L evil happens
right when marriages are female L evil
happens and I just see the same Trend
that whenever stuff is catered to the
woman and even family Dynamics it's like
we hear 20 years later that the dad
actually wasn't a bad guy the mom was
just shitalking him for 20 years or the
mom's encouraging her to do only fans
like I just see women we just are not
logical we're emotion emotions based and
I I just don't think it works so if you
submit to the man and you said about
cheating once is like okay but what if
it's multiple
times respect would you say like what
what would what would what's your
boundary you have to walk this this is a
hard pill and this was a hard pill for
me to swallow too at like at the end of
the day we know sex is different for men
and for women right we we know this like
there's something innate like that when
you hate a [__] you'll call her a [__]
right there's a reason we do this you
know there's something innate there's a
reason girls don't want to say their
body counts right because we know it
makes us less valuable and men they
don't care like their their body counts
don't matter and I know you said you're
going to break up with I don't believe
you for a second sorry you're not really
dumping a guy cuz he slept with a bunch
of people especially if you don't know
him I I wouldn't want to know I know you
wouldn't want to you wouldn't you
wouldn't want to know but you want right
come on and so but men it's like they
just have a visceral reaction because
for a thousand years if they picked a
promiscuous woman she was going to uh
like there was no way he would know that
the kid was his and then he could be
giving his resources to a kid that
wasn't his and today that's a big
problem I mean there's some estimates
that like 20% of men are raising kids
that aren't theirs and then you look at
the data for women in body counts you
know and if you've slept with more than
five people you have like a 20% chance
of a happy marriage and they can lose
everything because of this again this is
what happens when females lead um so the
cheating thing is we know it's different
right so I just think attent like
cheating for women is getting attention
from other men and cheating for men is
getting sex from other women because
okay if you could pick one like most I'm
trying to explain this in the best way
but most women would pick Beauty for the
rest of their life over money or sex or
if you asked men if they had to pick one
of the three they would pick sex or
money maybe but probably sex right you
know what I mean like okay if you if you
looked if you were like ugly but you got
sex from hot guys it wouldn't really
mean anything like we Value Beauty we
want to be beautiful we want to be
desired so it's like when we when you
have wives that are half naked right I
think that's equally as cheating as a
guy sleeping with another girl I know no
one no one really agrees with me on this
but my logic is I think women desire
attention and Men desire sex so I think
it's a bit hypocritical you know to come
in and you know I I just think sometimes
we got to get off our high horse and you
know we're not perfect and they're not
perfect either and I think it's silly to
break up a marriage because he's not
perfect but I'm not saying he should
cheat I'm not saying it's good I I would
be very hurt and I hope he do and the
worst part is all these [__] are
going to try to get him to cheat because
I've talked about this I just know it I
know how this is going to go but um yeah
I don't does that make
sense yeah I know it's a little it's a
little yeah yeah but yeah a lot to take
in so yeah but I just think I think what
they've done is really dishonest to us
because they've told us you are the
victim it's the end of the world when a
lot of times the reason he cheats is
because he's demasculate a lot of times
the reason he cheats is because he's in
a sexless marriage because women we've
been told we can do no wrong and we're
just victims for forever we never ask
about our part to play and usually when
a guy cheats the woman isn't innocent
like there are very few times a girl is
being perfect wife and he cheats and I
just I I think it's silly that we don't
ever look in the mirror first before
pointing the finger and you know so and
I think it can be worked through you
know there are people that found out
about a family across town and they
stayed and stuck it out like I I know
someone um you know I I have a relative
who her um he he had a whole side chick
and he left the family for the side
chick right and literally the side chick
died I know she and this woman was so
Catholic she prayed for a solution she
was like God God please bring like bring
my husband back like do you see how
different that mindset is like God I
just want my husband like please I need
my H they don't make women like that
anymore think about jool Lee that song
right now we have Taylor Swift songs of
a of a decade of her like getting ran
through and just being the victim and
poor me poor me and nothing like she
seems like a nice woman but nobody's
told her reality where you had the women
of 50 years ago joliee singing like
please don't take my man you know she's
like begging I need him we don't have
songs like that anymore we don't have
movies like that anymore it's never like
I need my husband it's I don't need a
man and I just think it's like
programming and brainwashing and I think
a lot of times women ruin good things
because we think we can do better and we
don't wait pill so you wouldn't mind if
your like boyfriend cheated them I would
mind I would be like no so would you say
like cuz I again I get I I listen and I
hear what you're saying but again it it
seems a bit black and white and it's it
can be Gray
no I think most things are pretty black
and white and I think that's how men
think I think women we have our emotions
so we're like oh and I know there's
there's a middle ground like I think if
he got a [__] pregnant I'd be oh I
think I think that might be but I would
still the goal would always be to work
it out like I think that should be the
goal like if you can work it out why
would you not work it out but our
immediate gut reaction is leave leave
leave and I just don't think that should
be the gut reaction I think the gut
reaction should be did I do anything
wrong how did I contribute to the
situation what if he's just like a guy
that likes to cheat you know I think
it's did you really not know that before
you got married well I mean yeah that's
why I'm single no that's why I'm not
married yet no right well I I I think I
think women it's like pick your poison
it's like we want a guy that's super hot
you know guys that are super attractive
are going to be tempted to cheat a lot
we want a moral High Ground right some
of them have good morals and good
standing okay so when you had moral High
Ground did you wait till you were
married where was your where was your
morality it's like I never no no but but
but I'm saying you cheat on your future
husb marriage is supposed to be two
virgins and the woman's virginity is way
more important than the males we know
this that's not happening so now they're
both they both are not whether their
body counts high or low it doesn't
matter but they're both not and they
both they've decided to be together and
get together so I'm I'm saying like
women don't pick monogamy when we have
the most choice so when do women have
the most choice at like 22 23 that's
when we have like you know the world is
our oyster we're we're we're the hottest
and we could do anything we can make
100K a month on only fans we could go
get married but women like we don't pick
monogamy but like men their Peak is like
35 that's when they're the hottest they
make the most money they've dealt with
women so it's like when they get the
most choice we immediately judge them
for cheating and we immediately but it's
like when we had the most choice we
didn't choose to get married married and
all I'm saying is maybe we could have
some understanding for it and see where
they're coming from because SE their sex
is in front of them 247 they're wired to
[__] damn near like we have phrases like
he'll [__] anything and that that says
that it's not as emotional as it is for
us like if we cheat we cheat to leave
you know what I mean like we're not
we're not she's not and we're like we're
getting out of this [__] but like when
men cheat it's just like God damn it the
stripper came on to me she was just
there these girls came these girls up
were chasing sent me down in the bar
because I was married like no it's true
yeah yeah and so she said Lily said
she's going to hit your boyfriend up H
yeah I'm not that's what I said that's
why you
know that's why people all right but but
this is this is my point it's like I
just think the goal should always be to
work through things but if he hits here
what about abuse in a marriage so you
know what's funny women hit men more
than men hit women once decided women
are women are much more violent than men
yeah I agree it's like we just can't be
violent that's the funny thing it's like
saying you know someone without a gun
well you didn't shoot anybody well they
didn't have a gun she stopped her no I
didn't but the the point is like so so
infants I'm gonna I'm gonna we'll Circle
back to that but but but infants and the
elderly they're actually much more
likely like women are more likely to
kill them so you know you know I think a
lot of times when you say oh he h hit me
well what did you do to bring that anger
what did you what did you what did you
do to bring that anger out of him I saw
a clip of a girl that insulted a guy's
dead son and was taunting him then he
then he freaked out and hit and
sometimes it's like guys just like they
can only take so much and they're
verbally abused so much and again I'm
not saying like you should accept that
right but again I think the goal should
always be to work through it did I play
a part and if you didn't you know and he
he's an abusive guy then my next
question is did you not know that before
yeah no I'm actually asking
hypothetically we're talking about
through through thick and thin so I'm
just throwing like I mean I'm a cath
like what you know what if this happens
in the well I'm a Catholic so I would I
would say separate and again make the
goal to be to get together that that
should be the goal you know I I know
it's like can can I speak from a man's
point of view because obviously I'm a
man um but pretty B Sure from from my
from my own male experience and from
most the men I know it's very hard and
it takes a very
certain types of circumstances for a man
to change who he is on the inside so if
a man is an abuser he has always been an
abuser like when women say oh well he
changed ining the marriage if he changed
during the marriage then you definitely
had a part to play in
it if if if he didn't change dur in
marriage then you you probably decided
to ignore the red flags victim BL I
think women do provoke men like because
the reality is if you look at if you
look at and this is what we said that
women typically don't pick the right
things so why why do we have a lot of
women that for some reason just always
seem to have a toxic ex we love toxicx
woman just have a toxic ex and and if
you look at the start literally how many
men are are dating these women so if all
of you are having toxic exes and more
than 50% of men are not even in a
relationship so what does that tell you
but also you have um the ex girl the
ex-girlfriends are always the crazy
ex-girlfriends yeah so it works both
ways it's the same that's my point
because it's the exgirlfriend is always
a crazy exgirlfriend right but that is
typically almost every woman but then
the men that are toxic are just a few I
think women do provoke men but I think
that like it's kind of like they do like
it a little bit when they get slapped up
wow I I mean so it's funny joke about
men getting slapped but if you were to
do that I never said it about men
getting I said women provoke men to hit
them but women like it oh wow you're
sick no what I've actually I'm not even
going to lie I hate to back I hate to
back her up a little bit I've heard I've
heard that from guys where they're like
oh like she wants me to be so like rough
with her you mean in bed no like yeah
in like Norm girls do provoke guys cuz
they like it and they want it like have
you heard of CNC I don't know what that
is consensual non-consensual it's quite
common we yeah okay I don't want to know
I don't want to know NOP NOP no okay um
but but yeah that's my that's my opinion
on abuse is I think you know there are
rare exceptions but I I just think the
majority of the time there's more to the
story because he didn't just come home
and say who can I can I abuse her today
I just today I'm I'm feeling abuse like
usually there's more to the story what
if he was what if he was actually an
abuser but he was hiding it because he
wanted to um you know he wanted to
change but it isn't his DNA or whatever
um King said um but he so he didn't do
anything until some I don't know what
happened maybe he had a really bad day
I'll Grant youen all right so you know
maybe after one time it's like can we
work through it you know
um I I just have a hard time believing
that that's really common in my opinion
but I'll give an exceptional divorce a
very but it's got to be you got to try
first so I'll give an
exception maybe maybe I'm still
hesitant and also I think like when it
comes down to choosing our partners I
think that that's why discernment is so
important and I think a lot of women put
looks at the Forefront put money at the
Forefront and maybe aren't thinking
about the character of the men like for
example like PA said you know there are
exceptions some some bad things can
happen that's we're never saying that
that's not the case but you know it
comes down to discernment and you have
to look at a man's character it's way
more important than looks and money and
I feel like a lot of women don't know
that nowadays they're obsessed with
social media they're obsessed with this
reality that it's a delusional it's not
reality it's delusional so their
discernment goes out the window and I
think somebody said before that's why
men uh fathers used to choose their
daughter's husband
and I honestly think that that does make
sense like I know it sounds
controversial but it does make sense
because men are going to be able to
discern the character of another man and
say okay I can see this I can see
through this I believe this is a good
partner for you and then obviously you
choose whether or not you want to go
with them but like for example for me my
dad's nepales so Asian and then my mom's
uh White and you know in my on my dad's
side of the family everybody had an
arranged marriage um and our
grandparents chose the wives of the
husbands and of the sons Etc and you
know those relationships I'm not saying
all but those relationships work better
than relationships where say for example
other other family members chose their
partners and then things didn't work out
so well down the line so I think that
discernment is so so big and a lot of
women want to play victim like oh he did
this to me he did that to me the red
flags were either there or you did not
do enough discernment because you were
too
in love in la la land and you didn't
look at the character to make sure that
you were choosing right so I'm I'm
curious from the checks all right all
right if you're who would pick a better
husband you or your dad who would make a
better choice if I you would to go back
you're 22 and a virgin who thinks they
would make a better choice than their
dad raised their hand it depends if it's
like happiness or no no no for what
would
work interesting which one was the first
one you get to pick or your dad so right
now we're saying you pick better than
your dad I mean yes all right three
maybe and a half all right who says your
dad picks
better okay interesting all right well
I'm gonna Read Super chats really quick
and then we're going to do final
thoughts give me one
second freaking okay guys make sure you
like the video how many likes are we at
King th6 th6 all right so 903 to pie
there is no difference between women
being sexist and racist just add color
when they say men it'll sound the same
Michael Williams the young lady said
that she is ready to be married with
whenever even her boyfriend of two weeks
is very refreshing to hear that's the
type of woman a man will take care of
and care for on another level she wants
a family and to be married the potato
sandwich get your gross feet out of the
camera view 93 toai Oprah invites you to
celebrate your only Fan sex success
along with Oprah's success what are you
guys talking about on the show Susan R
uh prove positive that glasses don't
make you look or sound smart U Matt
butcher great show but I can't help
feeling like we're picking on mentally
handicapped uh children keep working on
the reading skills uh Randolph um have
you ever considered how their behavior
will influence Society 30 to 100 years
from now um Jay marriage is worth
but if you work as a team and are open
to stand by each other love is difficult
at times but it's always worth the risk
Alexander the sofa 304 is reflecting um
reflecting man Parts with her brain size
P size outperformance wow these
feminists are really hypocritical
clothing options law and extra rules
cultural BS enter black dragon men's
biology testosterone is tied to our
sexual appetite to reproduce feminism
has tried to condition men to control
biological imperative while telling
women to be out of control and Reckless
Adam suton a man is cheating when he
buys a girlfriend a house this
conversation is ridiculous um okay I
read those I'm going to refresh it real
quick guys so if you have anything else
make sure you super chat it um okay
that's it so now we're going to do final
thoughts please no monologues you know
like 30 seconds or less is you know are
you not going to save this live video to
anything or is it just live yeah it's
just live oh yes it'll it'll be out
no she means like it's going to be safe
to your channel though isn't it yeah
okay yeah it doesn't go anywhere they do
Clips or
whatever um go ahead final thought okay
um so yeah peace and love to everyone
and uh keep it in your pants
people [__] hell I'm dreading to hear
[Laughter]
this um I just want to say to the girls
catch a [__] and to the boys if you want
to spunk really really hard go subscribe
to my any fans Lily Daisy Phillips yeah
I want to know how many bought I want to
see how simp my a I wna I wanna guys
guys don't s don't support this trust me
I've got nice no don't support it we
don't s here let me let no no no no put
that away put that away no subscribing
go
ahead um to be honest my final words
um I think just [__] whoever you want if
you're a boy if you're a girl just be a
virgin cuz everyone just loves virgins
apparently um she's getting it guys yeah
um if you want to get married then get
married if you want to spunk colot
subscribe to my only fans as well no
don't do that no no no guys no sing stop
it all all your followers are going to
no no no I actually am curious how many
do so let me know but no no subscribing
all right go
ahead um final thoughts I just want to
go to the club to be honest and um it's
already midnight so I need to be quick
and get ready so I can um catch a [__]
yeah catch a [__] tonight good
TR God uh follow me follow me at Alby
the artist and go subscribe to their
only
fans why would will
ler it's like he didn't even no guys
stop it stop it no guys no subscriptions
here go ahead and my final thoughts are
girls have some s with back guys just
wing it and yeah follow me lady. Harley
883 it's you yeah uh I don't know yeah
it's been it's been refreshing it's been
interesting uh it's just it's not black
and white it's definitely gray so no
it's completely black and
white do whatever makes you happy just
don't hurt anyone in the in the process
proess
yeah okay thank you for having me pal
it's been great uh my name is shristy
Jade and you can find my music on
Spotify so you can spell my name by s h
r i s t j a d e um my husband and I also
have a podcast where we do reaction
videos red pill reactions Street
interviews and chat a lot about red
content um so you can follow us there on
sjor Rose we're on YouTube and Tik Tok
and Instagram and thanks again po yeah
thanks for just really quick um so are
you just abused with your submission
yeah you does he wake up and just say
abuse today yeah throw brick yeah it's
crazy Upp you guys should react to my
videos well your only fans yeah um I
don't think that's gon to work on YouTu
but you know thanks for the
recommendation but no I think actually
can I say one thing I think that you
know submission and and getting a man to
lead I think that maybe if we just took
our emotions out of it and looked at
like Paul said the past how it worked
and to take away those negative Notions
from it because actually it can create a
really beautiful Union in your home and
yeah marriage is beautiful and is is
very special so don't let don't let them
fool you
yay um thank you for having me as well
um yeah no it was definitely interesting
to see all different viewpoints and
stuff like that and I don't want anyone
to think I hate them because of the
lifestyle that they choose like at the
end of the day it's do whatever you
want and yeah follow me on Instagram
islo
IO that's pretty much it well thank you
guys all for coming fun chat tonight um
guys a couple announcements before we
end the show first of all we are looking
for talent at the the jpt network um I
think we're going to sign like one or
two more people in London so if you're
interested send me your content on
Instagram just pearly things one um also
sign up do you have the Google form in
the chat I don't know blessing King want
someone make sure the Google form is um
in the description because we are going
to do a Meetup in London I know I know
I've been gaslighting you guys all
summer I promise we are doing a Meetup
and it's going to be fun so if you want
to come I think we might have like
musicians from the show perform and like
show guests are going to it's going to
be fun um also guys if you want to sign
up for the oneon-one membership tier
with me it is um the fourth tier and I
really can I am look it guys I am goated
when it comes to YouTube I just got a
girl monetized in a week and a half what
was it like eight days 10 days King we
are go we're goated so if you want to
know the secret has 275k views on
YouTube 275k views it's like we are
goated here at jpt so if you want to
know how we do it you want to know the
secret sauce sign up for the fourth tier
also guys um subscribe to her Channel
please we want to get her to 10K she's
at like 85 so she's really close so get
her to 10K um subscribe to her channel
the link to that will be in the
description thanks for watching and
we'll talk to you next time
bye